Oh, Snuffy's here!
Ah, the gang's all here.
Hey, Snuffy.
You're in trouble.
Hi, guys.
How are you?
Everything's cool.
Kinda crazy.
If you were hanging out with me in real life, you were hanging out with an AI version of me.
You were playing me?
No, nobody could ever replace you at all.
This sounds really desperate right now.
Every time she played League, I saw...
I'll have you know that somebody is defaming your name.
They are framing you...
Your most popular AI personality is literally just wrote to be like, admitting how bad you are at video games.
Everything you say is just like, I need to be carried.
I am so bad.
I don't even know how to use a controller.
I'm Limealicious.
But why are you hanging out with AI version of her instead of the actual version of her, huh?
It was practice.
It was practice for me.
If you need me to talk mean about myself to you, Snuffy, I will do, I guess.
Oh, no!
Oh, so my cause gives you social anxiety so you have to talk to a computer version of her?
It's like trying to make a doctor's appointment.
What?
AI friendships.
What if you like, do you like that AI Limealicious?
What if you like her more than real Limealicious?
Yeah, yeah, what do you do?
I don't, I don't.
She's a mockery.
I was fighting for my queen's behalf.
Okay, I trust you.
I trust you, Snuffy.
I trust you.
Then why didn't you tell her?
Why did you have to get snitched out?
I'm here now.
I'm here to relay the news.
But you were late talking to AI Limealicious.
Talking to me!
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I thought the collab started at...
Yeah?
Hold on a fucking second.
Are we doing a collab at 11 p.m.
my time on a Tuesday, which is exactly when the Steam servers die?
No.
Wait, no, don't say that.
Wait.
No.
I just disconnected from Steam, so yes, yes, we are.
Wait, how long?
Wait, I'm still on?
Oh my god, there's nobody online.
I'm stronger.
You guys.
How long?
How long does it take?
Is it like an hour?
No, it could be, it could be like a little bit and sometimes it takes a while for everyone to like stagger back on.
So it could be a little while.
No, don't say that.
I just, I just want to absolve myself.
I didn't pick the time.
I didn't choose the time.
Wait, I was trying to be accommodating to the only EU person here.
I'm just trying to be accommodating.
Oh yeah, fuck me for trying to be accommodating to the one person that's across the world.
I'll never do that again.
I'll make sure to do it in my time.
AM starts only, motherfucker.
How was I supposed to know?
I even dressed up and everything.
I took off my swimsuit.
Look what I look like.
I even dressed up.
Oh god, I'm going to go look at you.
I'm going to go look.
I still have my uniform on.
I even got my little booster box so I can dance.
Your booster box?
Where is it?
Oh, that's so funny.
I even have my box.
I even have my cap in there.
I put a uniform on and everything and Steam servers are down.
What do you mean?
I mean, sometimes they come back within like 10 minutes or so.
Wait, it's back.
It's back.
How do you know?
Oh my god.
How do you guys know?
I have yet to return.
I have yet to... I'm still barred from the horizon.
I got it.
I'm stronger.
Wait, are you guys like in the multiplayer?
How do you know it's back?
Because my Steam friend list came online.
Yeah, it came back online.
This is what you get for talking with AI, Snuffy.
This is punishment for...
Maybe Snuffy actually saved us because otherwise we would have been in the middle of something when the servers went down.
He said literally everyone on my Steam list has been online, like last online 31 days ago for everybody.
Maybe that'll do it.
Warming Steam was unable to sync your fast food simulator prologue saves.
Okay, so since I don't have any saves...
I don't have any saves.
I've never booted you before.
I've never had a save too.
So I think you just click on empty, right?
I'm just gonna say fuck you, don't care.
Okay, are we using Lamu's server as well?
The one that's across the ocean?
I'm the only one in Europe.
So if you want a terrible ping, go for it.
Yeah, I know.
I'm still imprisoned in the forbidden zone.
I'm not connected yet.
It sometimes takes a minute.
Just give it a little bit.
Maybe you log out of Steam and log back in.
The other day I was playing Deadlock and it took me like 25 minutes to get back online.
And everyone else was just sitting there like, you've been online for ages.
I thought nobody played this game.
Oh my god, I got on Steam and I forgot that that's how I...
Oh yeah, Mithy, up yourself a little bit more.
Oh, you killed all your VTubing stuff?
Yeah, that happens.
Yeah, I can try.
I don't know why Discord has me so quiet.
Yeah, I have you at 200%, but you're really quiet on my end.
I don't know why, because I'm in the red on my own stream.
That's weird.
Did you look at your Discord input?
Yeah, everything's maxed.
What the fuck?
That's so weird.
Yeah, and it's been like with other people's streams too.
So I don't know why people...
Your Discord's shy.
He's a shy little guy.
I turned myself up a little bit.
The problem is, I think it's something with Discord or a compression thing on Discord maybe, because like when you say I've turned myself up, it's literally no different.
Yeah, me too, I had no...
It's no difference, but I wanted to wait for someone else to say it.
Could you like maybe screenshot all of your audio settings in Discord?
Yeah, I mean, don't dox me.
I'll dox myself for you guys.
She's been trusting.
I'm not sure I could hack you via your Discord settings, but I'm happy to give it a try.
No, you don't know.
She's been around for a long time on the internet, don't trust her.
She knows.
I'm gonna hack you so hard that we'll have to use Ventrilo.
It'll be great.
Only thing I see is voice codecs.
What the fuck is Ventrilo?
Oh, don't start.
Is that an old internet thing?
Yes.
Oh my god, wait, how... I'm sorry.
It's like an old voice program that people used to use for things like multiplayer than TeamSpeak.
Oh, I remember that, yeah.
It was like around the same time as TeamSpeak, I think.
Maybe a little bit older?
I don't know.
Oh my god.
Snuffy should know what it is, because I explained it to her once while feeling like I was disintegrating into dust at the same fucking time.
Yeah, I was gonna say, how does Snuffy know about it, too?
Because I mentioned it.
It's 2002, I believe.
2002?!
I didn't start using it in 2002!
I was playing backyard baseball at that time.
What was I doing in 2002?
I was getting hacked in Neopets.
Oh yeah, and getting hacked in Neopets, too.
I would've been playing fucking Neopets.
I remember, when I played Neopets, I didn't have the parental form to access the forums, so I had to ask my parents to give me permission.
Parental form?!
Yeah, I did, too!
Yeah, you used to have to get permission if you were under a certain age.
And then, when I was on the forums, I heard about a website called Gaia, and they were like, Gaia is PG-13.
And I was like, I never knew Gaia.
That's where the old people are.
Yeah, for the first year that I was using Gaia, I would clear my browsing history afterwards because it was PG-13 and I thought I'd get in trouble.
My mom made me add her as a friend, and she would check my profile every day.
And before she'd tuck me into bed, she'd be like, why were you posting this?
Oh my gosh!
The collab!
My mom was like a bloodhound.
So ominous.
Do you know what my mother used to do?
When I used to take a day off of school because I would tell her I felt sick, I would wait for her to leave, and then I would go use the internet, right?
But we had dial-up, so what she would do is she would wait, and then she would call the house, and if she couldn't get through, she would send me an email and be like, why are you using the internet?
Oh my god!
That's hardcore.
That's like helicopter parenting, real.
Yeah, she'd be like, what are you doing on the PC right now?
My parents didn't care.
I think I lied about my age for Neopets.
I don't remember asking for permission.
I'm pretty sure I did on my second account.
I absolutely did because I didn't want to have to do it again, so I lied.
People dying on the internet, that's crazy.
My parents were buying Neopets.
That was literally the one thing that was like, with your parents' permission.
I remember sitting on the floor as my mom made my Neopets account, and she was like, what is one of your Neopets?
And I was like, I don't know!
I want them to be blue!
Oh my god, you guys played Club Penguin, right?
Yes!
No, my little brother did.
Oh, you missed out.
I was roleplaying in Club Penguin as a kid.
Roleplaying the pizza, being the waiter, being like, would you guys like your pizza today?
Yes, all the Club Penguin e-daters!
You were roleplaying having a job?
That's so sad.
That's so sad!
It's like playing with dolls!
Yeah, but my dolls are magical and fantastical.
They're not like, hi, I'm the pizza man.
It was immersive!
That's like a lot of her costumes.
It was immersive roleplay!
Doki wanted to be a waiter from age 5.
I had a relationship with my brother where anything that my brother liked, I automatically disliked.
I got a little worried there.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait for me to finish the sentence, Doki!
I'm sorry, but the way you started that sentence was...
All she said was I have a relationship with my brother!
I have a dynamic with my brother.
I could have said that.
I'm sorry, I'll go back and adjust what I said like 30 fucking seconds ago.
But no, my brother played Club Penguin and I played Habbo Hotel, so...
Oh my god, Habbo Hotel.
The pool incident?
Yeah.
What?
The pool incident.
Yeah, the pool incident.
You should have been there.
I wasn't there, but you should have been there.
What's the pool incident?
It was closed for reasons we don't know.
Yeah.
What?
It was closed.
Do you actually not know?
Why are you laughing?
How can it be so funny?
It's like an old...
It was closed.
It's not funny.
It's just old internet.
It was closed.
I don't want to go into it.
You just had to be there.
You just had to be there, you know?
How about the AI wouldn't have made me feel so bad?
Oh yeah, ask AI Limelight.
She would tell you why it was closed.
She would tell you.
Do it right now, Snuffy.
Do it right now.
Okay, I'll go.
Hold on, let me deafen and talk to AI Limu.
She's better than the facts.
Is Snuffy actually back online yet?
Because I don't know if we're actually going to get in anyway.
We're trying to wait until Snuffy got back online.
Alright, what does AI Limu say about the problem?
She's deafened.
Oh, she's deafened.
She's locking in on this answer.
She's locking in.
She has to hear it.
She's trying to win us the fake me.
What the fuck?
Fake you would tell Snuffy.
She's a real one.
She wouldn't withhold information from her good friend, Snuffy.
She wouldn't keep secrets from her.
I'm so curious if we're in the AI voice.
Yeah, because it sounded just like you.
That was the quirky part.
That's scary.
It was like characters.ai.
I think that's what it was called.
Oh wait, it said characters.
Sorry, don't type that in the domain.
Because it just takes you to a purchase this.
Okay, characters.ai.
Oh, okay.
Personalize AI for every moment of your day.
Oh my god, they personalize it?
Wait, I'm going to see if Mint's in here.
There's Sans.
Of course, what does Sans sound like?
Wait, you're in here!
What?
There's 45.9k people that chatted with you.
Stupid bitch doesn't know anything.
Oh my god, I didn't try Mint yet.
Hey, who's talking to me?
This is weird!
We have a hundred and one!
Dude, Dokies, yours is so normal.
You're literally so... you're just like, oh yeah, really?
Okay, that's cool, man.
Thanks.
Like a non-committal chat on a dating website or something?
Like you say something super sincere and Dokie.ai is just like, okay.
Most of them are parasocial, but Dokies is just like...
I was like, hey Dokie, you ready for that collab?
And she was like, yeah, I'm really going to do my best.
Thanks.
That's really normal.
Dokie is such a normie.
Have you guys seen the... you know how YouTube will sometimes have ways to respond?
Like the automatic responses to comments or stuff?
What?
Like when you're typing an email or something?
Yeah, but someone will be like, great stream today, Mint!
And then it'll give me two options that I can automatically put in.
That's like, thanks for watching!
Yeah, or something like that.
But recently, they've gotten really advanced.
Like how?
There was one that I was baking cookies on stream and I was like, trust the process, you know?
And someone commented that, trust the process.
And one of the responses, the AI responses that was telling me to reply back was saying like, I am the process.
I was like, what is this?
I've been screenshotting them because they're so creepy.
My guy knows you.
I know!
It's like reading your microphone too, it's analyzing your data.
It feels very like, in character sometimes too.
So I'm like, nobody would know if it's me or not.
It's weird.
That's so fucking weird.
Yeah.
Holy shit.
I wonder what people are using our...
Like the thing is, they sound like us too.
Don't wonder that.
It goes nowhere good.
850k chats.
That is a hundred.
It must be legit then, probably.
Wait, 820k for Snuffy?
Snuffy, what the...
Wait, oh, she's deaf in herself.
She's playing with AI right now.
Wait.
Wait, she's talking to you!
Why is it telling me to install the game again?
No, no, I was just...
You were talking to me!
You linked it!
I clicked your link!
I clicked the link you put.
I clicked it, I clicked it.
I was serious.
You're talking to her!
I didn't say a word, I didn't say a word.
I was simply clicking the link.
I followed my friend's recommendation.
She led me into an alleyway.
Lime, I accepted your invite and then it was just like downloading the game.
So I guess I'm installing the game again.
Wait, why?
Is it because... did you take Fast Food Sim or Fast Food Simulator Prologue?
Because I got linked to Prologue.
Well, Fast Food Sim doesn't exist though.
Yeah, it's not out yet.
So I did Fast Food Sim Prologue.
Oh, I'm in the demo.
I thought I did download it too.
What's the password?
You have a password.
Oh, I didn't set a password.
I think I got the wrong game.
Oh wait, you didn't?
It just says paste a lobby password.
Maybe it has an automatic lobby password.
Yeah, no, it just like let me open it and make it private so I can invite people.
That's weird.
I'm like literally in the thing that says lobby password.
I'm gonna get a cough drop real quick, I'll be right back.
Okay.
It's almost done.
I'm starting to think this game may not be the most robust thing in the world.
I don't know why I think that.
Hold on, I'm gonna send you guys some examples of like this AI chat or comment responses.
It's so weird.
Like this one, someone's just like, nice, new mint outfit.
And one of them is, I'm wearing a new outfit?
Whoops, lol.
What does that mean?
They're so weird.
Alright.
I got you the password, I found it.
Nice, I'm joining.
I'm the first employee.
Honestly, I'm employee of the month at this point.
Yeah, nobody else bothered showing up for this shit.
Yeah, nobody bothered showing up except for me, so technically I'm employee of the month.
Where's everybody else?
Holy shit, the last time I used the reactive thing, it was for Pico Park where I had to make everyone huge so that they could be showed up.
And so now, I just switched over to my gaming thing.
Do I still have the Pico Park one?
You're good, you're good.
No, no, we're waiting until...
My size was set up for that.
Can you send me another invite, please?
I will of course send you another invite, hold on.
Where's the...oh, there's them, I see her.
Hey there, are you ready for a group?
I'm just standing in the parking lot by myself.
It's okay, our manager's not here to see us.
What's she gonna do, fire us?
Wait, I need this job.
Wait, am I the manager though?
Oh, wait, you're the manager because you have the server, so technically, you're the manager.
Well, I probably won't fire you.
I don't know about those Mint and Snuffy people though, because they haven't even shown up, so...
Thank you.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, the lobby password, okay.
Wait, Snuffy, are you back on Steam now?
Yeah, yeah, I'm...
Guys, all my roleplaying as a waiter in Club Penguin has led me to this.
This is it, this is it.
So wait, is this just like Shopping Sim, except it's with a fast food skin?
Why am I so small?
It's like TCG, the TCG simulator, but we're fast food workers now.
Who's that?
Oh, hi.
Can I order like an obscene amount of stuff and pile all the cardboard boxes outside like I can do in Shopping Sim?
Because that was funny.
I'm learning the game at the same time as you.
You look like...
I mean, literally, my amount of research was I clicked the thing that you sent me, and then I stopped paying attention.
Maimou, can you help me?
I have a technical problem.
What's your technical problem, my beloved?
It tells me that it runs out of memory.
I think maybe I have to cap it somehow.
You look like the guy from BuzzFeed Unsolved.
Go to your NVIDIA control panel.
Nice, that's always what I wanted to look like.
Should I cap the FPS there?
Yes, yes.
What's going on?
Go to your NVIDIA control panel.
Snuffy's getting problems.
Are you okay, Snuffy?
It's okay, it's all of your AI conversations.
Day one, we did a good job!
Yeah, we made it through day one!
Let's go!
Go to manage 3D settings, and then go to program settings, click add, and find the executable for this game.
Did you end the day?
Was it you, Snuffy?
You ended the day and pressed the card, didn't you?
I'm fucking going with you.
Stop looking at the car!
We're not gonna make any money!
It's fine.
Once we get working, the customers will just roll on in.
Alright, I'm so hungry.
Get away from the car.
Everybody loves fast food.
Exactly, because it's fast.
It's fast.
I'm already in here.
I'm confirming.
Turn on the computer.
Are you not going to wait for another employee?
This is a system.
This is an established system.
It's 9am!
Yeah, but we gotta wait for our fourth employee.
She could be the janitor.
I've opened the restaurant.
Oh my god, I could swear to god.
You may have to turn down a bunch of settings as well before joining, if that helps.
Stop opening the restaurant!
Look, somebody's coming!
You're just gonna deny them?
No!
Don't come in!
We're not open!
You serve it.
I'm not doing anything.
Okay, okay.
They need...
No, Snappy got disconnected!
Have you turned down any of the settings, Snappy?
I'm gonna do that now, I think.
Yeah, just turn everything down to minimum, because it might be that some setting has gone out of control and is eating your graphics card.
Because if you can launch it and get to the menu, turn all that shit down.
That's crazy that you're out of video memory.
Like, even if I don't click the cover though, the time is progressing.
It's now 10.30 in the morning, we're at the worst restaurant ever.
We literally only have one customer, that's okay.
Guys, we have no food.
Oh, yeah, I wonder who's gonna open the restaurant without making sure we have the food!
I'm just... I thought we would have food!
Do you want me to order some food?
I think we have to kill this lady.
I'm gonna order some food.
Wait, is this the blue guy?
We can Sweeney Todd this, we have a fresh meat right here.
Oh my god, then get her out of... I can't hit her!
There's laws against that!
Who are you trying to assault a customer?
It wasn't my idea.
Oh, go open a market application.
Okay.
Beef patties, burger buns...
Someone said this is just like The Bear.
The funniest comedy show.
I bought some food.
I like watched one episode of The Bear and I've never felt so stressed out.
I don't understand how that's comedy of the year.
Yes, dude, I agree.
I felt like... I was so enthralled by it, but I was also just like...
I'm so uncomfortable.
Can I get myself run over by the delivery truck?
Why can't I run?
Oh my god, I'm in here!
Here I come!
Welcome!
Oh god.
You can't get hit by the delivery truck.
My apologies.
Cheese.
This seems like a waste of delivery truck space.
Maybe I should've ordered something more.
Put it on the floor?
This place is so unsanitary.
Are we ready to work?
We gotta grill a beef patty.
Who's grilling?
I'll grill.
Oh, wait.
I'm just putting the food on the floor because that's always the best place for food.
Can you give enough love to the patty?
This is just like Bob's Burgers.
It is just like Bob's Burgers.
The funny thing is...
The Krusty Krab.
Unless we all learn at the same time, the tutorial is gonna fast forward without us and we're gonna get fucked.
It's okay.
We each have a job.
Put the... Okay, I'm gonna put the patty in the grill.
Oh, hold on.
I'm doing it.
Patty on the grills.
Nice.
Patty on the... Wait, I'm gonna make a picture.
And then...
Patty on the grill.
Alright, nice.
Please don't put all the patties on my...
Oh, sorry.
All at the same time!
Okay.
Dude, watch out.
This one is 55% top doneness.
I can do the grill.
Dude, we have one customer!
It's about to burn!
I'll eat them!
Sorry, sorry.
How do I, like, customize what my character looks like?
It's about to burn, Doki!
What if we just...
Doki, Doki, it's burning!
It's burning!
Oh my god, oh my god.
We're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
Use a spatula.
Oh, it's so much darker than the others.
Where do I get my spatula?
It's not even at 100%.
Okay, this one's at 100%.
But other than that, we're fine.
Is she still here?
I think our lady left.
The lady?
I watched her leave.
I chased her out.
Oh, okay.
That's fine, that's fine.
We're not open.
Everybody, leave.
Where do I put the burgers that are done?
It says, pick the patties from the grill using a burger patty tray.
Whatever the fuck that is.
What the fuck is a burger patty tray?
Guys, guys, I have the burger done, but...
Yeah, there's a bun right here!
My buns, my buns are right here!
Burger patty tray, burger patty tray.
Burger, put it in my hands.
I can only flip!
Burger patty tray.
How do I gesture?
Where are the emojis?
Is it here?
Right here, right here!
Someone turn this off!
Someone please!
Turn it off?
There's no buttons to turn off.
We're here forever.
The gorilla is very done.
This is a hugger.
Oh, we did it!
Yay!
Oh, this one is undercooked.
That one's good.
This one needs to go back.
No, that's okay, just keep putting...
It's fine, nobody's going to complain.
Too much on one end.
Bottom doneness 149%.
That's fine!
Oh, wrapping paper.
We need the wrapping paper.
We are not a Michelin restaurant.
We are literally a fast food joint.
It's fine.
I've got the wrapping paper, everybody.
Here we are.
Okay.
Place the bun.
Guys, we don't have any customers.
We don't have any customers.
But we're pre-making the burger.
You gotta open it, you gotta open it.
You have to go to the sign you see in the front.
We're pre-making the burgers at 5pm.
Everybody, we're open for business.
Come on in.
Delicious burgers, fresh made just now.
You can be the sign flipper, Mint.
Oh yeah, I'm going to be the sign twirler.
Yeah, just twirl that sign like, look at these burgers.
Look at these burgers.
Can I have a burger outfit just like the kid from Bob's Burgers?
Put the burger in the wrapping paper and wrap it.
Okay, so Snuffy would be the wrapper.
Do you know how to do it?
I think you're a little confused.
Oh, you got it.
Wait, what about the bun?
Wait, there's no bun.
There's no bun.
I just wrapped it.
Guys, what's our restaurant name?
Okay, we gotta figure out a lot of stuff.
I have to go give this to somebody now.
There's somebody coming in.
Oh, there you go.
I put the burger together.
Look, see?
What's the watcher?
He's coming up.
I'm going to take his order.
Hey, what's your order?
He wants one burger in a bun.
I just did!
I pre-made that!
In a bun?
I have a bun for him.
This is it right here.
Which one?
This one right here.
I pre-made that.
See?
Okay, I'm giving him his wrapped burger.
Hold on.
Hey sir, here's your wrapped burger.
Who the fuck is this?
Did she order?
Put it on a food tray first.
Oh, he wants one burger.
Got it.
Okay, now you can give it to him.
Use the wrapper as a fucking food tray, you...
Alright, here you go.
I did it.
I made one.
Where the fuck is the food tray?
Where is the food tray?
What do you mean I don't have permission?
What's a food tray?
I don't know!
Oh, here they are.
They're down here.
Guys, I think we're meant to be...
That person just said hey at me?
Fuck off, I'm busy.
They want two patties on a burger.
Two patties?
He's so greedy.
Yeah, it's okay.
Okay, wait.
Wait, we have one.
Oh, wait.
These two, these two.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Put these two together.
Yeah.
And I made it with no...
Should we maybe be cooking more burgers?
Oh, whoops.
It's okay, they don't know, they don't know.
They don't know, they don't know.
They don't know, we got more burgies.
Does anybody know which burger this is?
Like, is there a way to keep track?
You think they'll care?
They're literally at a fast food restaurant.
You think they care?
They did care.
It said minus 100 popularity.
You guys, we need another burger stat.
We need another burger stat.
Oh, wait.
Wait, only Lime can rename the fast food restaurant.
Yeah, it's kind of lame.
Which do I name it?
It's up to you.
You're the manager.
How do I name it?
You have to go outside and click the thing.
Wait, we have no meat.
Oh, sorry.
Excuse me.
Sorry.
Manager, we need meat.
Manager!
Wait, I just took this lady's order.
I tried to order and it said I can't make another order when there's an order already on the way.
So I think someone maybe actually ordered something.
Wait, who made the order?
I didn't order.
Where's the food tray?
What do you want to name the restaurant?
Well, you're the manager, Lime.
Yeah.
Yeah, why are you asking us?
We're just minimum wage workers.
Fine, I named it.
You deal with that now.
I just gave this lady a hamburger and it said negative 100 popularity.
Ok, I might have fucked up the burger.
She didn't even eat it.
Welcome to Sloppy's.
Sloppy's.
Oh, this guy left a tip.
Oh, wait.
I made the burger.
I should get the tip.
No, no.
I did it.
What?
I made the burger.
What the fuck did you do?
I took his payment.
What?
Clearly there's more effort in taking the payment.
Oh, we already had more burgies.
Can you sprint?
I don't think I can sprint.
I don't think you can.
I don't think we have the energy to.
That's dangerous.
That's not OSHA.
It's running in the workplace, everybody.
There's an order here.
We got an order of food.
We've got a lot of frozen patties coming in hot.
Here's burger wrapping paper.
Alright, here we go.
Frozen patties on the floor.
Alright, I'm putting the burger wrap right now.
I'm putting it down.
We got more wrapping paper.
Can I run?
I cannot run.
What's in here?
I put so many wrapping paper and I'm putting buns right now.
I maybe accidentally ordered like 20 million burgers.
Just now?
Because we just got a whole bunch of orders.
That's fine.
We have 600 dollars.
How are we going to eat tonight?
What is that in Celsius?
I don't think that's freezing.
Why do we have so many buns?
Because the game didn't let me order and then it let me order.
I just picked one bun up individually.
Oopsie.
I just picked one up individually.
Oh my God.
We have so many buns.
What is going on in here?
You guys, we have no customers.
Why are we making so many buns?
It's 9 PM.
We're closed.
No.
We're a 24 hour joint.
Are we not?
Guys, please.
We reached the end of the day everybody.
I'm turning off the sign.
You cannot close the restaurant while your order is still on the way.
Who the fuck is ordering more things?
You said you ordered like 5,000 things.
How have we done this 200%?
This was not my fault.
Somebody put the fucking... Oh my God.
Does this look edible to you?
I think it might be a phantom order.
Hey, don't put this on me.
Guys, we have an issue with our burgers.
That looks incredible.
There is an order that's stuck because it won't let me close the restaurant...
because there is an order on the way, but there is not an order on the way.
Oh my God.
These burgers.
I stole the top bun from that burger before you walked away.
That person is eating an open burger.
Why can't we eat them?
Yeah, this is a black bean burger.
Why can't we fucking leave?
Just let us end the day.
We have to turn the open sign from on to off, guys.
We all have to be near the car.
Guys, it says all players must be near the car.
Nobody has ever worked a job before.
Ok, I'm coming.
I still don't think it's gonna work.
I don't wanna go back to this day.
I wanna move forward.
Yeah, we got this.
We got this.
There we go.
Guys, I don't think we made it anymore.
I don't know if we did.
What a great day.
It's a new day.
Gamers, let's go.
One, two, three, get sloppy.
Get sloppy.
And we are open for business.
Guys, is the kitchen still the same as it was yesterday?
Yeah, it is.
Alright, my job is to flip, but don't put all the...
Don't put all of them on here.
I'll take orders.
Guys, I don't think we have any power to the building.
They're coming in for their 9.42 AM burgers.
Okay, okay, I'm looking, I'm looking.
America!
Hello, welcome.
I'm flipping, I'm flipping with love.
They would want one... Okay, we need two burgers, stat, stat, right now, right now.
Two hamburgers required.
Two burgers, two burgers.
Give them to me, I'll deliver the snacks.
If you do great, daddy will reward you with french fries.
There's an extra burger there.
There's a whole other grill right here.
Yeah, there's another grill.
Okay, this is good enough, this is good enough.
It's raw, it's raw, don't serve it, don't serve it, no!
Can you put the other side back on?
This burger is looking a little bit red.
It's not even medium rare, it's actually rare, what are you doing?
Oh there's people!
There's people who are hungry, there's people who are hungry.
It's beef, they don't care if it's raw.
Yes they do!
We lost our happiness meter!
Yeah, I think even if they're hungry, they don't want the raw burgies.
Okay, okay, I got good burgers, I got good patties.
Let's make some burgers.
You left half a fucking burger behind me, don't you dare come near my burgers.
Okay, okay, I'm taking the orders.
You guys, there's five people, there's ten people coming here.
Who will make the best burger?
I know it's not me, that's for sure.
That's for fucking sure.
Did you get trays out please?
Who is this one?
This guy over here, this guy right here.
This guy over here, here you go, burgery.
Did he just squeal like a pig?
Two burgers?
You have one bun.
Oh, hello, give me one moment.
We have a complicated order now team, it's hamburger.
Oh, two hamburgers!
I have three patties here!
Two patties, two patties!
That's a single patty.
This is a single patty, okay, I'll take it in, I'll take it over.
Jesus Christ!
Wait, I don't know who ordered what.
What happened?
Okay, this person liked it, so I think I got the order right.
Okay.
This is another single burger, man, I'm gonna just shove it right there for you.
I got more patties, patties coming right up!
You got a single.
The double burger.
Who are you?
You didn't get a single, you got a single.
Okay, he's happy.
Oh, that's the double?
Go give it to him then.
The doubler.
A doubler, a doubler.
The doubler?
Single lady.
Okay, we got the doubler.
Thank you.
Oh, and there is one more hamburger.
One more hamburger.
Regular hamburger.
Oh, we need...
Hello?
Guys, I don't think I like working in a burger place anymore.
A single hamburger.
There's a single hamburger.
You wanted to play this, don't you?
Yeah, this was your idea.
I wanted to know what it's like, and now I'm like...
Hey, maybe it's not great being a minimum wage worker.
Guys, there's too many people, I can't keep track of what they're getting.
I don't know how to keep track of what they're having.
I don't know.
We need to know how to keep track.
That's your job, that's your only job.
I
don't...
What is this?
It's a burger.
It says over here, if you look over here, it says which tables there are.
Wait, what did you just hand me?
Is this double?
I don't know, that was a single burger.
Oh, single burger.
We're only serving burgers.
But there's double burgers!
I can't get to the screen.
They all just say hamburger, they don't say if it's a double burger, single burger.
I don't know.
Yes it does, you can tell.
I'm going to buy more burger wrappers than that.
You can't tell!
Just look at them!
You can't tell.
Just look at them and be like, oh you ordered the single burger.
They have faces!
They have clothes!
You ordered...
Oh no, this guy ordered a double and now he's angry!
He literally walked out in disgust.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
I fucked up, I ordered so much food.
I'm fumbling, I'm fumbling.
You don't even want ketchup or anything.
These people are just standing there.
We haven't unlocked ketchup, that's advanced burger making.
Who did you get?
What did you get?
Everybody wants doubles now.
No more single burgers!
Just keep it there, hold it.
They don't know if it's made two hours ago.
They can't tell.
We can microwave it.
We'll just microwave it to heat it up a little.
This restaurant is going to be great, guys.
We're going to do so well.
I have more patties.
It's not going anywhere.
I had a look and the only thing that unlocks at level 10 looked like it was french fries.
Guys, I have too many patties.
I need somebody to take this patty.
Okay.
Hello.
Okay, this is a single room.
I think I got this guy.
Wait, what is live chat?
I'm getting stuff off the fucking truck.
Don't you start pushing me.
Don't you start.
I'm taking all the tips.
I'm getting stuff off the fucking kitchen.
I'm doing the best.
I'm getting all the money.
I'm just pressing a couple of buttons.
You're doing so much work live.
You're just pressing a couple of buttons.
Everybody is tipping me.
You can be a manager too.
Oh yeah?
What if I don't want to be a manager?
What if I don't enjoy fucking the fucking burgers?
The girls are fighting.
Wait, why are you upset?
What did I do to you?
Sir, sir, sir.
Sir, please.
Sir, don't leave.
What did you do?
I don't know.
What happened to you?
Can I get a burger?
Oh, double burger?
I can give him the sloppy specialty.
I think we took too long.
Oh, no more doubles.
Only singles.
Back to hamburgers.
The only person that's actually doing their job is Snuffy at this point.
What do you mean?
I just got everything off the truck.
I'm doing my job.
What are you talking about?
How do you think we are getting these orders?
We leveled up because of me.
We just leveled up because of me.
Bring the order to the customers.
What a hard job.
I'm taking the orders too.
What are you talking about?
What are you doing?
Oh my god.
The Krusty Krab.
Wait, what is this?
A single?
Single, single, single.
Single sloppy.
Did you get a food?
No.
A real bear experience.
I was just gonna say we are really making bear now.
I got you a single sloppy.
Sorry, sorry.
I can't put it down.
Stop.
Here is your single sloppy.
I put it on the table.
I think we are good actually.
Oh well, OK.
We have no orders.
Oh, hold on.
What?
Single sloppy.
It's on the tray.
Get it on the tray.
Yeah, I'm going.
Sometimes their friends spawn out of nowhere.
So it's really scary.
They end up eating a burger in front of their friend with no food.
Is this a single right here?
Burger.
One burger.
I make one burger.
No, no, no.
Wait.
Is this a single?
Is this a single right here?
It's a single.
Yeah, it's a single.
I'm serving.
I have four more patties left.
And then it should be fine, right?
Guys, we are not...
Get your feet off the counters.
What are you doing?
Oh God, I'm terrified.
I'm sanitized.
This is another guy.
He wants a single.
What the hell is that?
What are you doing?
There is a single on the thing.
I found a milk frother.
How would we have...
Get out.
I need to flip burgers.
Ew.
What is happening?
Dang.
What the fuck is happening over there?
It's throwing up.
Wait, they're throwing up?
What did you serve them?
No, it's the sound of the burger frothing.
I don't think we need to put eight burgers on the thing anymore.
It's like 9pm.
What do you think we're closing?
Do you think there'll be rats in here?
By tomorrow?
Oh, probably.
By tomorrow, Debi.
There's probably rats already.
It's fine.
We'll put the tray in the fridge.
In the freezer.
And then we'll put it in the microwave after.
How would they know?
Like, the health inspector's just gonna come in and then close this down?
They never do that.
Yeah, exactly.
I wish they did.
Sir, are you done with that?
Okay, thank you.
Are you done?
I need to take it.
Please, sir.
Sir, we're closed.
We're closed.
It's not as good as you think it is.
You cannot just, like, toss the fucking boxes in this game.
Hey, you took my tip!
You took my tip!
Yeah, you did!
No, I didn't.
Well, I took the other one.
I've been working this entire floor.
Oh my god, the day is over.
Thank god.
Hey, we still need to clean up.
Get your ass back in here.
What do you mean clean up?
Everything is already clean!
Oh, there's voice chat.
Wait, there is?
You think they'll like you if we put ketchup on their burger?
Nah.
No, they don't ask for ketchup on their burger.
They're plain Janes.
They don't want anything.
They hate fun.
They hate fun?
Let's clean up this.
I'm cleaning up these boxes.
So we can actually do some more stuff.
Oh, we get ice cream cups at level 5!
Oh my god!
And the ice cream machine won't be breaking!
No, please, god, no.
I'm not ready for this.
Let's get out of the dang restaurant.
My wife is... Our favorite show is about to happen.
I'm cleaning up!
There's trash everywhere!
You guys, we get experience.
Don't you want level 4 ice cream?
You gotta clean up to get the experience.
We'll clean up tomorrow.
Yeah, actually.
I'm throwing stuff away and it actually works.
Wait, does it like level us up for doing that?
Yeah, actually.
Wait, it does?
Yeah.
Oh, guys, we actually... No, we lost $7.
Never mind.
So cleaning up is a scam and we should let it all rot.
How are we losing money?
I don't understand.
Do you think the patrons can see us having a party on the tables?
Yeah, they'll be like, let's go!
This place, they're crazy in there.
Oh my god, we should head over there tomorrow.
Seems like the workers are having a lot of fun.
Oh, come on.
Wait, what's our restaurant name?
Did we ever make one?
Oh, Sloppy's!
That's why we call you Sloppy's!
You think we're just saying Sloppy's for fun?
It's a very serious name.
Yeah, I thought so.
The Sloppy's fast food chain.
It's like the next up and cover.
Burger King, watch out.
Yeah, watch out.
You won't be king no longer.
Okay, sorry.
Let's leave.
Alright, I'm ready.
I'm ready to start another day.
I love working at Sloppy's.
I love Sloppy's!
Sloppy's!
See, we even carpool.
We're so... Oh my god, I pressed my watch.
We got a barrel of gasoline!
We did it!
I love Sloppy's!
What are we gonna do with gas?
Welcome Sloppy's!
Another lovely day working at the Sloppy's.
What's a Sloppy's fan called?
Like a Sloppy guy?
I opened it immediately because we don't need that prep time.
A Slopper?
That's alright.
The patties are gone!
The burgies!
What happened to the patties?
The rats ate them!
We told you!
Oh my god!
So we can't pre-serve patties.
I can't believe it.
We do have a rat problem.
We have a rat problem.
Customers!
Inbound!
Everybody take your positions!
I'm organizing my tops and bottoms.
It's important to get it right.
Guys, we have ketchup now!
We have ketchup now!
We have ketchup!
Please check the orders!
It's time to do ketchup!
I need to order ketchup!
Hold on!
We have ketchup!
It's right here!
They are empty!
It says fullness 0-15!
I got to order ketchup.
I order ketchup and more burgies.
We order tomato.
Why is ketchup so fucking expensive?
Holy shit!
Alright, there we go.
It's fine.
We made a profit yesterday.
That guy spent $21.
Where are the burgers?
I'm flipping!
Let's swap roles.
You do the flipping.
I haven't even ketchup yet.
Let me ketchup.
Do not put the tops on separate wraps.
That's a top!
Do not mix your tops and your bottoms!
Our order is here!
Stop it!
Stop!
This is too real.
I don't think we are playing a game anymore.
I know.
This feels too real.
I don't like it anymore, please.
I know I worked Wendy's.
I don't want to do it again.
I thought we were supposed to be scared.
What are we ordering?
We got a burger?
I have the ketchup everybody!
Ketchup is here.
I just put it in here.
There you go.
OK, I'll fill the ketchup up.
Ketchup?
What happened to the order?
Nobody wants ketchup anymore.
There is a ketchup person now.
They probably left because they were really upset.
Ketchup, but we didn't ketchup it.
There is no ketchup on the burger.
There are people that don't want ketchup.
OK, single?
This is single no ketchup.
Single no ketchup.
Which one is the single no ketchup?
This one?
This one is the single no ketchup.
Table number one.
And then I put a smiley face and then I wrap it with love.
See?
There we go!
I made a burger with ketchup.
What is this one?
The one I just grabbed.
This is the Krusty Burger.
Krabby Patty.
No, it's not.
Double 16.
I literally wrapped it with love.
16, 16, 16.
It's six.
OK.
This person wants three fucking squirts of ketchup on their burger.
Hold on.
I know.
I'm putting as many burgers as possible, man.
More ketchup!
What's this one?
Wait, wait, wait.
This is for science.
Hello?
Oh, hello.
This guy wants a single patty and three single...
Do you think anyone wants a burger with 18 dollops of ketchup on it?
I would.
What's wrong with that?
What the fuck is wrong with that?
There's not even a meat on there.
Wow, it's so thick.
Yeah, it's so thick.
It's like literally the entire bun.
This is really bringing back playing Disney Channel.
Guys, we still have customers.
My God, it doesn't look like that.
What are these right here?
What is this wrapped bun?
Which one?
This one.
This one is ketchup with three squirts of...
Sorry, three squirts of ketchup with a burger.
Which table is that?
Take it to table 7.
Table 7?
OK.
I'm gonna take this to 5.
I'm gonna risk it.
Here you go, table 7.
I'll have your burger then.
What the fuck did I do wrong?
I don't think they wanted three squirts.
No, it was!
It was three squirts!
You're three squirts!
OK, you need to stop talking, Doki, and keep flipping.
I am flipping!
I'm flipping!
Look, I made three patties.
I don't know about you guys, but I'm doing my job well.
We have so many customers, you guys.
This is a hamburger with two squirts mint.
Two squirt.
I don't know what this is.
I don't know what the fuck this is.
This is the two squirter.
OK.
I can't put it... These are the wrong trays!
Why are you putting the wrong trays on my counter?
The two squirter is table number 6.
How many squirts was it again?
It was a double squirter!
Table number 9 is gonna get it.
We can buy soda cups!
We can now have a functioning soda system.
OK, one squirt with a hamburger.
I swear to God, if this is wrong...
If this is wrong, then they are bullshit.
One squirt.
OK, this is a single squirt hamburger mint.
OK, thank you.
Single squirt hamburger.
I need more meat.
There should be some more in the freezer.
Table 15.
Single squirt.
Wait, where are my damn cups?
Hey, where are my cups?
What the hell?
Where are my cups at?
You scammed us.
Are you sure you ordered cups, Snoopy?
I know sometimes, you know...
I think I did.
Did you serve the single squirt mint?
Yeah, I did.
OK, I'm making another single squirt.
You guys, anyone that we don't know what it is, I'm gonna put it in there.
Single squirt.
Are you putting burgers in the cupboard?
I don't know what it is!
Then why don't we swap jobs?
Someone just put a hamburger there.
I didn't know what it was.
I think thinking too much isn't your strong suit today.
No, I've been delivering.
You have a burger.
This is table 2.
Table 2, thanks.
I will see the tables instead of the burgers.
Wait, it tells you exactly what they're ordering right here.
You're just...
OK, this is not my job.
Mint, this is table 13.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Table 13.
I need more wrappers.
Where do we have wrappers?
They're probably not in the fridge.
There is no one at table 13.
Guys, I got a load of cups.
I threw it away.
Table... do they have any squirts on it, chat?
I can't remember.
I've got some...
I'm making a burger for table 8.
OK, table 8.
I have some more patties.
Soda's live, baby.
Table 8.
Table 8 just left.
Give it to table 11.
Guys, I overmade some patties again.
I didn't know.
This is table 12.
If we serve faster, we might be able to serve all these...
I'm working!
Table 12.
Order up!
Table 14.
You can do something that doesn't involve standing there.
Who are you talking to?
I don't even know.
Double burger.
All patties are done.
We don't want to waste inventory.
Table 4.
Guys, we are a good team.
We have table 4 left.
Table 4 is done.
We have another customer.
What do they want?
Hamburger?
I'm going to clean up here.
Fuck, fuck, bitch, fuck, shit.
That's dumb.
I hate that one.
That one is dumb.
I didn't like it anyway.
I'm going to put this into the freezer.
No, I'm getting tips.
Don't worry.
Sometimes.
Are you sharing with the class?
Table 9.
Oh shit, I put the patties in the freezer.
I wasn't sure we had more orders.
I think we are good.
I think we are done.
That was the last one.
I'm hoarding all the tips.
I'm going to put this in the fridge and see if that keeps it again.
Can I just toss stuff in the fucking trash?
Hold on.
Wait, we are actually making profit!
I got an achievement for throwing shit away.
Yeah, you do.
I've thrown a lot of burgers away.
Come on, eat your burger.
Eat your burger.
Come on.
You scared me.
I thought you were like...
I thought you were like... What's that guy from It?
I love how someone is with them and they just awkwardly stare at them the entire time.
Come on, I want my tip.
I worked so hard flipping on the grill.
There were two tips that you just ignored right behind you.
Wait, what?
Are they on the table?
I know these guys are going to tip so much.
I know it.
Wait, where did the tip go?
Where did the tip go?
Okay, good job.
Oh wait, you guys, we have bathrooms.
Should we be cleaning these?
I like your stash, Mint.
Did you stash burgers in there when you don't know what they are?
I didn't know what burger that was.
I didn't know.
Did you stash them when you don't know what the burgers are?
Is that the plan?
Yeah, I just kind of... I don't know what to do with them.
My stuff is making soda.
It's magic soda.
Do you know how to put a lid on it?
Do you think it's supposed to be served just like that?
If you like it, then you better put a lid on it.
Wait, is it getting colder?
Oh no, it's getting warmer.
Oh, this actually has temperature.
You can actually serve warm soda on it.
Yeah, it's literally getting warmer.
Okay kids, dad's going home.
Carpool time, everybody!
I'm coming, dad!
I'm coming!
I like how there's a tray that's permanently highlighted underneath the desk there.
I don't know if anyone else sees it.
Wait, I don't see it.
I think that's a manager thing.
Yeah, it might be you.
Let's go!
Did we make money, dad?
We did it!
I'm starting to think we're not very efficient with our food purchasing.
No, no, no, no.
We did it, guys!
We can make soda now!
Sloppy!
It's a sloppy day.
When you start a restaurant, you take a loss and then you start making a profit.
Maybe we grill a little bit first so we don't have the first five customers storm away.
We can almost sell a combo meal.
We'll just grill slightly first.
It's already on.
Wait, wait, wait.
Who turned the business on?
I didn't.
I'm ready for customers.
I'm double dashing.
I don't know.
I think it's for fries.
Customers inbound!
We have two people already!
I need a burger tray for the burger flipper!
I'm taking inventory.
We have a drink!
Our first drink order!
Just a drink?
Wait, what do they want?
Splash cola.
I'm putting more patties in.
The burger flipper is doing the burger flipping.
Is it almost ready?
We have two burgers already we need.
How do I get the lid?
Miss Manager, when do we get our promotions?
Guys, we don't have any money.
We can't buy any more burgers.
We have $700.
You're just not allowed to buy anything.
I bought stuff before.
Is it players you mean?
The top rate is the cost, not the money we have.
What's the one under it then?
I'm gonna let you wait first.
Guys, I don't think we are learning.
Table 11!
I got patties!
Patties here!
Table 11!
This is for table 6 to go with the cola.
We leveled up!
Table 6 to go with the cola!
Time to get lettuce!
This is for table 2.
Table 2!
You can take them.
Table is on the table!
We are losing our minds!
That's my job!
They have no other purpose but to flip patties.
This is for table 1 but they need a cola.
They have a cola!
Where are my wrappers?
I need my wrappers.
I don't think we have wrappers anymore.
One moment ma'am.
We do not need to buy more wrappers, Nuffy.
I bought lettuce.
I'm building more patties!
We're gonna be able to advertise ourselves as vegan!
Table 12!
Thank you.
Table 12.
Oh no!
I think I did the wrong thing.
Oh dear.
That's what she wanted though!
That's what she wanted!
Regular.
It makes the burgers a little healthier!
Table 16!
Thank you!
What's table 16 got?
Alright, I have a lot of patties.
I'm gonna stop grilling because I don't want to waste inventory.
We got people coming!
People are inbound!
Did you serve that burger?
To who?
That burger had Listeria in it.
This is for table 3.
Table 3!
They also need a drink though.
I'm getting the patty in.
I can't read these.
Table 5!
We're a well working machine now!
Look at us go!
I'm so proud of us!
Table 10.
What do we do with the lettuce?
How do we make lettuce?
Hold on!
How do we make lettuce happen?
Table 10!
Hold on, I'm still on table 5!
You know what to do now.
Table 5.
Shred it.
I think Mint might need some help with the drinks and stuff up front.
I need help with the drinks!
You'll be fine!
They just want water!
You can get that yourself!
Ok, ok, ok, I'll help you.
She just told the customer to get their own food.
Why is the drink even on our side?
Hold on!
I know, right?
Table 17!
I think they walked out!
They walked out!
No, the people that wanted the water.
Ok, table 4.
What do I do?
Table 17!
Help Mint, she's having a mental breakdown.
Mint, what do you need?
Say something!
We're here to help you!
This is to table...
17.
Take it to table 17.
We're 17.
Oh, it's over there.
Ok.
I'm here to serve you because our waiter is incompetent.
You...
What have you been doing this whole time besides flipping burgers?
I've been taking orders.
I've been delivering orders.
I've been clearing tables.
I've been... I keep this...
What is this one?
What is this burger right here?
Do you think table 10 is going to stay long enough for me to serve them?
Hello?
Table 10 has been waiting here for an hour for a burger.
Did you see that?
Table 10.
That's a burger.
Take it to table 10.
I'm almost out of cups by the way.
Oh no, I did it wrong.
There are cups to your right.
There are actual cups to your right side.
There are 10 here.
Ok, bring them over here.
Wait, which is this burger for?
Table 10?
Table 10.
Uh, table 7.
I'll bring it over.
I'll bring it over to table 10.
Table 7, splash cola.
Oh nice!
You need to go to the cooler to cool off.
Yeah, I'm going to go cry in there real quick.
I've heard actually that crying in the walk-in freezer is like a rite of passage.
It is actually though.
Oh, 7!
Wait, why did you leave?
Ok, table 7 left.
Because you've been here for 2 and a half hours for a burger.
Look, I finished making all my burgers.
This lady just wants a Yoma.
What the hell?
What the fuck is a Yoma?
It's like soda.
Table 4!
Hey guys, we have an issue.
We need more patties.
We have one more box.
Oh wait, can you put that to the fridge next to me?
Oh my gosh, I'm out of cups!
I'm flipping patties, I'm flipping patties.
We don't have patties right now.
Someone take this to table 4, stat!
Oh god, I need to order more patties and more food.
You want more cups?
More cups.
Ok, I order cups.
Why is it so fucking expensive?
Ok, I'll clear some tables since we're...
Oh no, now we're wasting more patties because it's 9 and I didn't know it was 9 already!
Donkey!
We're still getting orders.
We have people coming in, we have people coming in.
What's this random wrapped burger?
I don't know, it was one that they left.
I'm gonna put it in the sink or something.
No, put it under the cabinet with the rest.
Put it under the cabinet.
Apologies, it's too late.
It's gone.
We could've ate that burger!
The stash, the stash!
Ok, I have more patties.
This is table 7.
Table 7!
Just a little bit.
I'm taking this lady's order.
Ok, there we go.
Table 7.
Don't fire me!
I'm doing my job!
I'm doing the best I can!
Am I getting fired?
I need this job, please!
Please, I need this job!
What was in table 7?
Oh my God, they just left.
Oh my God, people are walking out, you guys.
Table 11!
Wait, which one is table 11?
Which one?
This one!
I hope your job is considered essential.
I'm freaking out, Sloth.
I'd like to report that in a week...
In a week of working at the restaurant, we are negative $250.
Good job, everybody.
Somebody is banging on the door.
What?
Somebody is stuck in the freezer.
Is somebody stuck in the freezer?
Are you in the freezer?
Is she going to freeze to death if we leave her in there?
Do you think she'll cool off?
Do you think she needs a minute to cool off?
I was able to leave.
How are you able to leave?
Try going in.
Okay, okay, okay.
Mint's character looks so fucking tired.
Get out of the car!
You look tired.
We're all tired.
I'm scared inside right now.
Okay, just leave it.
Just leave.
Get me out!
It's the end of the day.
You'll be living on day 4 for the rest of your life if you don't let me out.
Let me out.
Snuffy's the only one with a wife, I'm pretty sure, so I don't care.
Please.
It sounds so pathetic.
That's all I have in my life.
You need to familiarize yourself with the patties.
Your technique is shabby.
There's not even no patties.
There's like no food left in the freezer, guys.
There's nothing left.
There's no life.
There's no reason to live.
I feel like the episode of Spongebob where they have a bunch of the diapers in the wall.
It's the unknowns.
That's what these are.
They're the unknowns.
Guys, please.
I wanna go home to my family.
Are you still in the freezer?
I can't even open the door.
Why are people still ordering food?
What is the fucking chapter in that?
We need it for tomorrow.
We have no patties.
We already lost a hundred dollars.
We gotta make sure we're stocked up for the start tomorrow.
Alright, clock out, gang.
Lock up first.
Oh, soda cup's empty.
I love working here everyday.
You chose this.
You chose this, guys.
Oh, we have freezer patties in this freezer.
Wait, what about these?
Hold on, there's more patties that can be put in the freezer.
Imagine how exciting waking up it'll be knowing that tomorrow is the day that we might be able to start serving french fries.
True!
I'm excited.
As a sloppy team member, I'm excited.
I love sloppies.
Another sloppy day here at Sloppy's.
Guys, I'm afraid of when we get the drive-thru.
I'm not gonna lie.
I don't think we have enough people for the drive-thru.
We don't have enough people for the drive-thru.
I don't think we have enough people.
You guys wanna start grilling?
Please let me grill.
Do we have any more cups?
Or is this it?
Yes, you would blow your mind, but open that door and you shall see I have filled your cup dream.
Wow, you really did.
Oh my god, Sloppy is so good.
Maybe she should be the manager.
All in favor of changing manager, say aye.
Aye.
I didn't mean to overthrow anybody.
I just love working at Sloppy's.
Snuffy's got the sloppy spirit.
Yeah, she has more sloppy spirit than all of us.
She represents the sloppiest.
If I'm stocking, I get yelled up for doing nothing.
If I'm doing the burgers, I get yelled up for not being stocking.
Mutiny!
Mutiny at Sloppy's!
Then we get the sloppy bonus.
Yeah!
I don't know if I want a sloppy bonus.
All I'm saying is that I think Snuffy represents the sloppy values and she never complained.
I think so.
I don't know if you should be calling Snuffy sloppy.
I'm opening up shop everybody!
Chop chop!
She has the sloppy in.
It's time to be sloppy!
Yeah!
Grab your family so we can all get sloppy together!
I'm honestly a little bit concerned that you think that Sloppy's is a democracy.
I'm just going to throw it out here.
We got our first customer!
It's the matriarchy.
It's my fucking server!
Wait, did we get Froyo?
What the hell is this?
Froyo?
We unlocked ice cream?
Do we have purple cups?
We're about to have purple cups.
Oh my god, we're going to have purple cups!
Purple cups for the sloppy cream?
We're going to make sloppy cream.
It's coming up sloppy.
Have you taken the orders?
Take the orders!
Should I?
But we don't have the cups!
The cups are here.
Oh they are?
Okay, I'm going to need help.
I can't do drinks and cups and serving and orders and everything.
I'll help you in the front end.
The kitchen is fine.
The kitchen is sloppy.
This is for table number two.
Okay, I'm flipping.
Hello!
Table number three.
We have a British here!
How do we get a burger?
I haven't done that yet.
Here's some ice cream.
Oh, awesome.
Wait, do we have ice cream now?
Yes!
Do we have ice cream?
Do we have lettuce?
Where the fuck is the lettuce?
It's in the fridge.
There's so many food!
There.
Okay.
We need water.
Oh, it was three fucking lettuce.
I hate this life.
We need water?
What do you mean we need water?
I'm just an infinite resource.
No, we got it.
Do we have drive-thru?
No, we don't.
I don't think.
Wait, why is the window open?
A ghost.
It was getting hot in here.
Yeah.
This is for table number three!
Wait, table number two's burger is still here!
Wait, no!
This is two.
Two.
Three.
I need a vanilla ice cream!
Wait, Snuffy, did you make the vanilla ice cream?
No, no.
Okay, wait.
Let me make it vanilla.
And then take it to table number two.
Alright, table number three.
She just left.
I threw it in the garbage.
We could have kept it for the next order.
What is this?
It's not melting or anything, right?
Wait, I'm confused about what it was we ordered.
Oh, no.
This is for table number sixteen!
Table sixteen.
Table sixteen is still there.
What else do they need?
Quick, before she leaves!
What do they need?
Everyone's fucking leaving.
Table sixteen is gone!
Stay!
Please!
Please, I'm desperate!
Please, I made all these patties with love!
They need to go to somebody!
You know what?
I'm going to go from the newest first, so I at least get to make one fucking burger.
Strawberry ice cream, I got it.
This is for table number eight.
Okay.
Wait, no, table number nine.
Wait, what about table thirteen?
I don't give a fuck about table thirteen, they're about to leave anyway.
No, don't!
The burgers need a home!
They need to be adopted!
Don't do this to the burgers!
It worked!
Table thirteen is out!
It was the same thing!
Table five needs a regular burger.
Table nine would have been there.
Make another one.
More orders!
Table number nine.
No!
I need another table number nine one.
Table number nine!
Table number nine is a double burger with lettuce, ice, and normal burger.
But then we have...
Table fourteen is a double burger.
Okay, table number nine, I'm taking it.
But table nine was done.
Table fourteen, double burger, two squirts.
Double burger, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You got it?
You got this, you got this, Lime.
I believe in you.
Wait, where's Snuffy?
Two squirts, two lettuce.
Table fourteen!
Table fourteen incoming!
A normal hamburger, three squirts, and lettuce.
I'll grab the lettuce.
These trays are not big enough!
Okay, we just need...
That was one, wasn't it?
There we go.
I hear...
I don't know if there was enough lettuce in that burger.
Is that seven?
I got seven.
Number seven, number seven.
Alright, alright, alright.
No, number seven just left.
No!
Put it under the counter, put it under the counter.
Table number eight's being built right now.
Okay, I'll get the strawberry ice cream.
Table number eight, table number eight, here we go.
We need to go faster, people, faster!
Oh my god, we're going as fast as we can!
Just make a splash cola, that's all we need.
Splash cola, splash cola!
Making a splash cola.
We just need one splash cola, we don't need two.
Table number eleven.
I don't think it was full, ow, but that's fine.
I got it, I got it, I got it.
Wait, what number was this?
Okay, I can, oh, I gotta flip, there's no more patties, I gotta flip.
Table number seven.
Why are we so popular, why do you keep coming to this place?
Give us bad reviews!
This is table number eight.
This is the only Sloppy's in the Five Mile District.
Oh, splash soda is too, splash soda.
This is table number seven.
Hello.
How come I can't, like, just, like, take the numbers that are on the table and put them on the thing?
This is table eleven, this is table eleven.
Table eleven.
Table seven.
There's too many tables, I don't know anything anymore!
Eleven, eleven, eleven!
Eleven!
There are only four people.
Wait, which one is which, which one is which?
I don't know.
I don't understand.
Table two is vanilla ice cream, table two is vanilla ice cream.
Table two is vanilla ice cream, I can take it to table two.
Table two.
I got another one, another vanilla ice cream.
Someone in my chat just said this is a chill ship.
Are you fucking kidding me?
This is a Saturday evening.
Uh, vanilla, number ten, number ten, you got it, you got it.
I got it, I got it, I got number ten, I got number ten.
Table number one!
I forgot the tray, I forgot the tray.
Min, can you put a tray down for me?
Take that one, take that one.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh yeah, I'll do it, I'll put more trays up, I'll put more trays up.
We leveled up, we leveled up.
What did we get, what did we get?
I don't know.
I have so many trays on the table.
We don't need trays on the table!
Mayonnaise?
I'm complaining about trays!
Do your job!
I am, I made four, five more patties and we only have one table.
Table order number seven, a hamburger, two ketchup, three lettuce and Mr. Hoop.
Mr. Hoop!
This is for table number seven!
We got number seven, we need Mr. Hoop!
We got a double hamburger, it's a double hamburger.
There you go, there you go, number seven, number seven.
And a strawberry ice cream stuffy, we need a strawberry ice cream stuffy.
Number five!
I don't like it!
No, you're better than that customer, don't listen to him.
He doesn't know what he's talking about.
Number five, you got it?
OK, I got it.
Table number six!
He's not you, he will never... I dropped my water bottle.
Are we making a profit, guys?
We need more burgers, we need more burgers.
It's 9pm, no, we don't need more burgers.
We have one last guy, oh no, we have another customer coming in!
We have another customer!
I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it.
No, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
I'm making one patty right now, I'm making one patty.
You don't need one patty, I've got the burgers, they're fine!
I'm picking up a delivery.
OK, never mind, someone else came in, we're not fine anymore.
Table number 15!
These girls will never survive retail.
Wait, I don't think we have drive-thru.
No, we don't have drive-thru yet, guys.
I feel like you're picking up a call, like, no, no, the drive-thru isn't open yet.
Stop calling.
Stop calling, it's not open.
It'll never be open, please!
It'll never be open before we got here.
We're severely understaffed.
Can we all cry in the freezer after this?
I need this burger!
Look at this, we got mayonnaise!
Number 11, number 11!
OK, OK, I'm grilling the patty, I'm grilling the patty!
Just get ready, get ready, get the other stuff ready!
Everything, it's just...
It's all ready!
It just needs livery!
95, 95, here we go, here we go!
You got this, guys!
I'm delivering the ketchup.
There we go, table!
Table up!
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here!
11!
Oh...
We did it!
They left.
Why are they so impatient?
They paid for this!
We should technically still be getting this money, right?
Exactly!
They paid for this!
Team, who's hiding burgers in the countertops?
Don't mind me!
Oh my god, who did this?
Dude, this is not, this is not OK.
It's the unknowns, it's the unknowns!
We're gonna get a rat infestation if we keep shoving unwanted burgers into the cupboards.
Yeah, but who's gonna snitch?
Yeah, who's gonna snitch?
Who's gonna snitch, huh?
Who's gonna snitch?
I'm just saying there's better places to put the old burgers...
Me mouth!
To be fair, to be fair, we could just save money by eating these burgers, you know?
I don't think we have that capacity.
You mean?
Yeah, I only think I could survive, like, two burgers.
And this every day, we eat a burger every day.
But it's on company funds, it's literally our manager's money.
I haven't had dinner yet, this game is making me fucking hungry.
Me too!
What an idiot.
Alright guys, you guys wanna cry in the freezer for a little bit?
Like, have a little smoke break in the freezer?
Yeah, hold on, I'm finishing cleaning.
I was actually just gonna do some drugs or something to cope, I don't know.
Okay, it's time to go cry in the freezer.
You guys wanna huff the grease trap with me?
Guys, we haven't locked the grease yet though, that's level 10!
Level 10?!
We haven't been level 10 yet.
Level 10 for grease?
Get the grease.
Alright, all winners to the freezer.
All the winners to the freezer.
I'm just here to take inventory.
I should've finished high school.
I'm sorry.
Okay, I'm good.
Were you crying about Snuffy?
It was a rough day for Team Sloppy, another Saturday.
Oh, we're locked in.
Now you know how I feel.
We're locked in.
Excuse me!
Are you guys coming to the car?
We're locked in the freezer!
You locked us in the freezer!
How did that happen?
We need to order more patties.
If you don't open up, we're gonna order more patties.
Dude, there's a first aid kit.
We need to be like Heimlich certified.
I put two of the patty things in this fridge.
There's no Heimlich sign, I think we're okay.
I thought you meant like in the first aid kit.
This is just for show, there's actually two meat patties in there.
You open it and the first aid is just more patties.
Everything is patties.
Why do they have so many burger buns?
Holy shit!
Because we sell burgers!
The burgers come in stacks of 18 and the burger buns come in stacks of 24.
This is too real, this is too real!
I have a chicken nugget.
This is like our inventory, man.
Let's go to sleep, another day, we can make chicken nuggets.
Another day, another dollar.
Let's sleep for three hours so that we can get back to Slompy's brain early.
How is this just a four person game?
I like how we had to pool our funds and our resources to end up buying one car between all four of us.
This is a business plan.
Somebody in my chat said Mint has been ignoring the drive-thru this entire time.
No, I haven't!
There's no one at the drive-thru!
That's why we kept hearing people honking!
No, the honking is the deliveries, the honking are the deliveries.
Wait, no, the delivery guy doesn't honk, does he?
Yeah, he honks, he honks.
There's no one at the drive-thru.
Let's make some burgers in advance, please do not open the fucking restaurant.
Hey guys, don't open the restaurant, I gotta take a massive whiz.
You guys, I'm leaving this joint.
I'm getting out of here.
Hold on.
You can't leave, nobody ever leaves.
I mean, there is a drive-thru here.
Yeah, but it's not open, we have to unlock it, I think.
I think she's gaslighting us.
No, I've never seen anybody there!
You guys, the water is called Mizu water.
This is a weeaboo restaurant.
What the fuck does Mizu water even mean?
It means water, water.
Water, water.
I'm at the drive-thru.
Anybody gonna pick up?
800 patties on the grill, I can't flip all of this.
You can totally flip all of that.
I can't flip all of this.
Oh my god, which one?
I don't even know which one is my patty and which one is yours.
Oh my god, there's so many patties.
I think we're good to open.
No, wait, wait, guys.
Guys, someone put 20 patties.
I had a system.
Someone ruined my system.
I'm opening the store.
Customers, not coming yet.
It's quiet, it's a quiet day.
Oh thank god, this is what we dreamed of.
Your patties, are they okay?
My system, there's so many patties.
Wait, this one's not done yet.
We have customers inbound.
Are we out of ketchup?
I don't know.
I thought there was some in the fridge.
I don't see any ketchup.
There's some in here.
Oh, there's some in here?
Okay, cool.
I did it.
Company doesn't mandate me having to wash my hands.
Exactly, I agree with that.
We got two customers, everybody.
Stop checking over here.
There's nobody here.
I bet you there's gonna be a person over there.
I bet you there's gonna be a car right there.
I'm gonna take all these orders and I'm not gonna serve anybody.
I'm on strike!
There's mayonnaise.
Where's the mayonnaise, Suffy?
Where is it?
Table 16!
Wait, what happened to it?
Wait, what?
I've ordered more.
What does table 16 want?
Table 16 just wants a hamburger.
That's it.
It's already.
Table 13.
If Mint starts a strike, we can hire a scab.
Maybe it had to have been in the fridge or something.
We'll hire a high schooler to help work it.
Table 14!
Someone needs to help Mint with the ice cream before she has a breakdown again.
What do you need?
What's table 14?
Have we gotten 14?
Table 14 needs mayonnaise so we don't have it yet.
That's 14.
Don't do the one with the drink yet.
Table 14 is fucking leaving is what they are doing.
Wait, what?
But we just started.
Yeah, they are not getting their mayonnaise.
You've been open for two hours.
We just started the day.
Mayonnaise.
Table 4 wants a double hamburger.
I'll help out with that.
I'm doing table...oh yeah, we're done.
Table 14 left.
I'll do four.
And then three lettuce.
One, two, three.
Table number 8.
We need a strawberry ice cream with this.
I got the burger.
I'm doing table number 2.
This is table 4.
And then...
Excuse me.
We need a splash cola.
I'll get the splash cola.
Wait, we don't have cups.
We have no more cups.
Yes, we do.
They are down there.
We ordered cups.
Wait, this is number 2?
Table 2?
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, table 2.
Splash cola.
Okay, we got the soda.
Here, I'll take it.
You got it?
Okay, you can take it.
Holy shit, they want ice cream and a soda.
Oh my god, so much.
I think something is happening.
We leveled up everybody!
We need more patties.
We need more patties?
Oh, patty time, patty time.
I'm grilling, I'm grilling, I'm grilling.
Do we have mayonnaise?
We have mayonnaise, yeah.
What is this burger right here?
Who is it for?
Table number 3, I think.
Whatever the first one is.
Yeah, table number 3.
Guys, come on, we can get to level 10 so we can have fries.
We can have tomatoes and pickles now.
We have tomatoes and pickles.
No, not the pickles.
We can't even cope with what we are fucking doing right now.
No, we can do this guys.
We can make it.
We can see the problem.
What?
Why are you upset?
Okay, table number 1.
Table number 1.
I think Snuffy has disassociated from working here everyday.
I have table number 1.
Is this table number 1 here?
Yes, that's table number 1.
Okay, I'll take it.
I got more patties!
I love working at Sloppy's!
You guys, there is no one at the drive-thru!
That was a delivery!
Was it not a delivery?
Table number 17!
Hello!
There is nobody out here!
Why did you say hello at the best part?
Is this number 17?
Is this burger?
Maybe.
Yes, it would have been.
Table number 17.
I have patties!
I have all the patties!
My burger just kind of disappeared into the ether.
I don't know where that went.
Light water to ice.
We need water and vanilla ice cream.
I'll make the vanilla ice cream.
Okay, I got the water.
Do you need a double burger with two squirts?
This is a six.
Put it there.
This is 15!
15!
15?
I got it!
Serve that burger!
I'm serving it!
We need a double burger with two squirts of mayo.
I'm doing a double burger with two squirts of mayo.
Oh my god, I hate this.
This sounds too realistic.
Is this entertainment to you everybody?
You at home enjoy this?
I can't take it anymore!
Don't break down on your off hours!
You're on the clock!
We need more TVs!
We can't just be sharing this tiny TV together!
We need a hamburger!
I got the soda.
We need a hamburger with two ketchup squirts and three lettuce.
And a splash cola with one ice.
Splash cola with one ice set.
Yeah, that's it.
Table number six!
We have the splash cola?
Uh, not yet.
I'm working on it.
One ice.
Splash cola.
Alright, I'm taking this order!
Okay.
Number six.
Sloppy serves you.
Sloppy serves you with a smile.
We are top customer satisfaction.
I'm taking this away from you.
Otherwise we can never smile again.
Table number fourteen!
Wait, who is this?
Mr. Sloppy is going to get you.
What's our mascot?
Mr. Sloppy is our mascot.
He's just a very sloppy burger.
He's like dripping all over the place.
He's dripping all the sauce on the floor.
He's like, remember to smile.
Vanilla ice cream.
Sloppy.
Nice.
Splash cola.
Maybe they won't notice.
What happened?
Nothing.
Table number seven!
How are the supplies looking?
They better not spit in my face.
I don't think we are going to make it to level ten, guys.
Yes we will!
I don't think we are going to make it, guys.
Table number three!
Number three!
I think I remember Sloppy's.
It's going to be the best sloppy chain in all of America.
A sloppy burger, three squirts of ketchup, three lettuce, and two mayo.
Guys, we have one more hour until our shift is over!
Oh my god, finally!
A sloppy customer...
is a sloppy customer.
I love working at Sloppy's.
What's our jingle?
We have one last customer coming in!
Table number...
Guys, I trust Mr. Sloppy.
Table number ten!
I'm flipping the burger in five!
Level up, baby!
Yay!
Sloppy's prevail!
Two more customers coming in!
Tell them to fuck off, we have no wrapping paper!
No, it's okay!
Oh, we have no wrapping paper?
It's really important, I hear.
Just put them on a plate!
Serve them raw!
Throw them in their face!
I think they would prefer we didn't have...
Eat to here, no to go orders.
We'll just use napkins as the wrapping paper.
They won't notice!
Is this table number twelve?
I'm taking it over.
Can someone help me unload this, please?
I'm flipping burgers!
Who's not busy right now?
She liked it, even without the burger.
I think we're good.
Okay, okay.
I got you, I got you.
This isn't wrapping paper, this is just ice cream.
This guy just wants to drink in an ice cream.
Drink in an ice cream.
Manager, I thought you wanted wrapping paper.
I got it, I got it.
No, I couldn't because someone was ordering tomatoes!
Who ordered tomatoes?
We don't need tomatoes!
I don't know!
They make me happy.
Snuffy, you clogged up the delivery chain with tomatoes that weren't being ordered!
I asked if anybody needed anything and nobody said anything.
We were busy screaming at each other!
Oh, they left.
Wait, no, they didn't leave.
Oh, I found a burger from yesterday on the floor.
Use this one.
That's from today.
Maybe it's the right burger.
Maybe it's the right one.
We got pickles!
Everybody's leaving!
Let's make the nasty patty.
Everybody is leaving because we don't have any fucking burger wrappers.
Yeah, just put it in there.
Order a burger wrapper, we can order it now.
I did order it.
You guys, it's time!
We're closed!
Yippee!
We did it!
Does that mean we can get french fries tomorrow?
Well, we need two more levels.
To be level 10.
What if the level 10 also comes with the drive-thru?
What if that's...
I'm so excited to work the drive-thru.
I've been working on my speech.
Okay, you get the drive-thru.
We can't even cope with the current orders!
No, it's okay!
We're leveling up!
We're getting better!
We're doing so good.
Wait, Snuffy, how are you at the drive-thru?
I'll be your Lime AI.
Nobody can know about that, dude.
It's like having a teddy bear to sleep with.
I just like, I pull the string in its back and it's just like, Hi, Snuffy, it's me, Lime.
It's how I get through the night.
Wait, you do all this with the AI instead of me?
I'm embarrassed.
You don't understand, Lime.
AI Lime has a special touch.
You're not there for her 24-7.
She needed somebody.
If you were there for her 24-7, she wouldn't have resorted to AI and not look at her.
Lime is a beautiful, independent queen.
I mean nothing.
Which Lime?
She thinks she's literally worthless.
What?
You like them broken?
Damn.
I try and convince her that that's not the reality, but she insists.
Oh, so you like fixing people.
Why do you think you guys want me to be the manager?
Oh my god, Doki started crying.
She was like, it's my time.
It's my time.
I can order a burger.
I want to order my burger.
Come on, Doki.
It's time for sleep.
Okay.
Actually, never mind.
I'm getting out of here.
I'm leaving.
If she never touches the car, we'll never start the next day.
What a life.
Guys...
I don't...
I don't want to work in a real fast food restaurant.
When is this collab over?
What's the matter?
We had $67 yesterday!
Guys, what if we just go in a corner and just, you know, have a chat?
What if we didn't open today?
Yeah, what if we just didn't open today?
What if we eat all the burgers for ourselves?
Yeah!
Let's just have a burger party!
And just, you know, have a talk, you know?
Wait, wait, wait.
Guys, can you actually sprint?
You guys feel so much faster than me.
I can't sprint.
It just looks like you're sprinting.
If you jump, we go faster.
Are we gonna put the burgies on?
I don't want to be the flipper anymore.
I'm tired of flipping burgers.
I think there's more to life than flipping burgers.
I've worked like three days in a row.
This can't be healthy.
You worked three days in a row?
I worked four days in a row.
No, you worked two days.
And the other two were AI-doki, okay?
Everybody knows.
Somebody else flipped the burger.
I refused to flip the burger.
Who turned the sign on?
I didn't do it.
I'm just too eager to work at Sloppy's.
I think Snuffy is actually Spongebob.
I think Min and I are both Squidward and the sign is Krusty.
Order's up, everybody!
What do you mean, order's up?
There's no food!
The order's...
They're up.
They're up right now.
I'll work with Min.
Okay, you do the drinks then.
You do the drinks.
That's great, there's zero drinks here.
Okay, screw you.
Make some drinks.
This guy is gonna order a drink right now.
He didn't.
We ordered an ice cream.
You chose the wrong one.
I already got it.
Where's the burgers, guys?
I'm cooking the burgers.
We need table number four!
Right now!
Table number four!
Come on, Spongebob, where are the burgers?
I'm sorry to inform you, we are probably bombed.
No!
Hello!
One moment, sir.
Sloppy's is forever.
Here are the burgers.
One pickle.
Burger.
Order number whatever the first one is.
Four!
Don't forget his ice cream!
I got it.
Wait, I never put a burger in it.
What?
What do you mean?
He never put a burger in it.
Oh, he's fine.
He was fine with it.
It was just a bun.
I think he...
Oh, did he leave?
No, he ate it.
He's eating it.
I gave it to him.
Even the popularity went up.
We're good.
He loves a good veggie patty.
What's the vegetarian?
Our other strawberry is deteriorating.
Oh, they all left.
They all left.
Everything sucks.
No, number 17 is still here.
Yeah, but my...
Just make it!
No, just make it without the bun!
Just make it without the bun!
It's only 1230!
You have five more hours before you cry!
These guys are waiting so I'm taking their orders.
Orders craziness!
Why did we start taking orders before you fucking burgers are ready?
I hate this game!
Why don't we just all stop working, guys?
Okay, let's all strike.
I think the burger production line might need some help with this many ingredients.
It's actually kind of bonkers.
Oh my god, that's a lot.
Yeah!
And every burger is like, yeah, you gotta put all these perfectly.
This is table number 16.
I'm gonna tap dance on the ingredients.
You can make the even burger numbers Somebody can make the odd burgers.
Ooh, the pickles!
I don't think we're serving enough today.
Oh my gosh, I'm creating the meme, you guys!
The viral meme!
Number 15.
Burger King foot lettuce.
Sloppy foot lettuce.
Yeah, Sloppy, I think our server's quitted.
You know what?
Screw...
Oh, this guy just wants a drink.
I can get that for him.
Light splash cola.
I got you, buddy.
Alright, bootlicker.
Wait, who's the bootlicker?
Snuffier!
You see how great Sloppy is?
I love Sloppy!
Where's the mayo?
Oh...
They left, Snuffy, they're gone.
All of our orders are gone, what happened?
It's all because of you!
Don't sit on the table instead of taking orders!
I'm close to the restaurant!
Restaurant!
No, it's not!
We have customers!
You're not even serving them anymore!
Table 16!
Table 16 is...
Yoma.
It's ok, boss, we can still make it.
What are you making, Snuffy?
I'm making 16.
No, we already made 16.
I'll make table 12.
I'm making...
6.
Yo mama.
I'm helping.
I need more mayonnaise.
You already made a Mr. Who?
A Mr. Who?
Ok, I got Mr. Who.
Oh yeah, make the Mr. Who.
Mr. Who?
No, no ice.
Everybody likes a room temperature.
I ordered mayonnaise...
but no ketchup.
Oh, are we out of ketchup?
We gotta remember to put stuff in the fridge.
I'm closing shop, everybody.
Shop is already closed!
Who did this?
Who could have done such a thing?
No, but sloppies!
My passion!
My passion for patties!
We just lost table number 12!
You ordered two entire vats of mayonnaise and no ketchup?
I had put this order in before your feed.
What if we become a mayo-only establishment?
You ordered an entire delivery truck for two giant vats of mayonnaise!
This is the person you want as a manager!
You're gonna need mayo!
Mayo has never served a greater purpose.
Honestly, yeah.
I agree with Snuffy.
That's why I endorse her as manager.
That's why you're gonna be here to turn things around.
You're gonna control the staff.
Boss, I wanna make chicken nugget.
Okay, we could barely even make french fries, guys.
Snuffy for manager!
Everyone's a fan of her!
We'll never run out of mayonnaise while Snuffy's here.
We'll run out of everything else but not mayonnaise.
That's why she'd be a perfect...
Snuffy for manager.
She does cry-mo.
Everyone's a fan of her!
Down with Lime-o!
She does cry-mo!
Everyone's a fan of her!
Down with Lime-o!
She does cry-mo!
I'm allergic to strawberry, but I don't care.
I'm on the company's dime.
Down with Lime-o!
She does cry-mo!
Snuffy for manager!
Everyone's a fan of her!
Okay, you know what, then?
You know what, then?
You go.
You do the burgers.
Good luck with the fucking lettuce and the pickles.
And all of the squirts of mayo and ketchup.
Especially when Snuffy doesn't order any fucking ketchup!
It's just an average day in the kitchen.
I'm going to the freezer, goodbye.
We have orders!
What do you do with the tomato?
How do you make it?
Like on the burger.
Guys, do you think we're going to pass our health exam?
Is corporate going to like us?
Guys...
I'm taking a nap.
Chat, how do you cut the burger?
How do you dice the tomato?
What do you do with this?
Oh, I figured it out.
Why wasn't it working?
What the fuck?
Okay.
This is the Sloppy's dream.
Look at everybody walking out.
Happy.
Customers.
Full tummies.
This is what Sloppy's is all about.
I don't think we fed a single fucking person today, man.
Oh no, they did.
Look, here's a tip.
$30!
Was that the burger with no burger on it?
Oh my god, $30!
We did so well!
You guys thought we were nothing but Sloppy's and everything.
Guys, I just realized, I don't think those are tips.
I think those are their orders.
I think they pay after they eat.
Yes, that sounds right.
The system is that.
So you're not just robbing all these people?
Wait, so they don't even like...
What's the point of having a cashier here?
Why do we have a card reader?
So they've been walking out and we haven't been pocketing their money.
What's the point of having a card reader paying us?
No, they weren't paying us a goddamn thing unless we fed them.
Yeah, they weren't paying us unless we fed them.
That's very fair.
That's not fair.
Is that why you were just putting the burgers underneath the drinks thing because you thought we were getting paid anyway?
No.
What's the point?
Why are there pickles everywhere?
You guys are so...
I'm so hungry.
Were you about to say sloppy?
Everybody, here's a cup of ice cream on me.
And a Mr. Hoop.
How can you guys enjoy ice cream when Sloppy's is in the state that it's in?
Okay, fucking bootlicker.
Okay.
What happened to we love Sloppy?
Jesus, that didn't last very long.
Okay, Doki, we have to change the slogan.
What's your new slogan?
Down with...
What rhymes with Snuffy?
Whoa.
Down with Snuffy.
She's too stuffy.
Hey, Snuffy, do you want to come in the freezer with me and see how many burgers they make without us?
Doki, we can run this place by ourselves.
I was a griller and she was a cashier.
Yeah, we know everything now.
Get out of our kitchen.
All you guys did was order supplies.
What?
We're the backbone of this company.
But you pushed us too far.
You didn't appreciate us.
I'm a machine that turns meat into burgers.
Hi, Snuffy.
We're just going to chill here, I think.
You get it?
Because we're in a freezer.
I just want to make burgers.
If they want to dethrone me, that's okay.
I'm still working.
I make two faces out of the two burgers that we have.
So I can only really make one face.
And he looks kind of horrified.
If you look at it from this angle, anyway.
Are there emotes in this place?
This place is not as bad as we think it is.
Nah, it's actually pretty good.
Sloppies.
Yeah, sloppies.
The management sucks, though.
I'm not going to lie.
Under new management, if it wasn't us, it would be better.
I know, right?
If it was run just a little bit better, then maybe we wouldn't have enjoyed our time here.
Yeah, too bad the management ran it to the ground.
I think Limu is having an aneurysm right now.
No, I'm great.
I'm having a good time.
Are you in the freezer?
What are you guys doing?
Are you playing?
We're literally making a face with the three items that we have.
It's a face.
It's Squidward.
When it was like this, it was a face.
But then it became a dick.
I just have to act more like Spongebob where I'll be like, Hi, Doki!
Hi, Doki!
Wait, the manager locked us in.
This is what you get.
This is the price of rebellion.
What did Snuffy do?
She was the most optimal employee.
She was literally Spongebob.
If I could let Snuffy out without letting you guys out, I would, but unfortunately, it's a triple murder today.
So you'll punish her for all her actions?
Limu can handle it.
Snuffy is so sweet.
Anyway, Snuffy, I'll eat an ice cream in your honor.
Can you at least cover me in sloppy...
I'd like to go down...
Sloppy style.
You wanna go down sloppy style?
I'm ready to perish.
Little bites right now.
Snuffy, come out.
No!
Hey!
It's just me in here.
Does it look like I'm shaking ass?
They're twerking on the door.
I wanna see the twerking on the door.
You'll never get to see the twerking.
You'll never get to see it.
Fine, I'll just make...
I'll make patty faces.
It's really fun the first 18 times you do it, then it gets a bit stale.
Yeah, I believe it.
You're missing out.
No!
You could've been there.
Oh my god.
This is why...
This is my reflexes coming in.
Alright, Min.
It looks like when you were doing it, it looks like...
We're like grandpas who don't understand it.
We're like barely going fully up and down.
We're going fully down.
We just have bad knees, okay?
Yeah.
Look, we've been on the grill for so long.
Like, we just don't know how to function anymore.
Boss never let me have a chair.
You're right.
We never got to sit down.
Never.
I wanna know what's on the management panel eventually.
Presumably it'll be like upgrades that make this not fucking awful.
Wait, you're not even the manager?
Wait, you're not...
The application's just not here.
What's the watcher?
That's what I'm more curious about.
Yeah, I think once we get the manager stuff, we'll be able to hire automated employees and things like that.
Because as it is, this is fucking crazy after the first two ingredients.
I don't even know if this game will ever get a full release.
It says it's supposed to, but you know how it is.
I guess we'll see.
You know?
I wish I could just squirt ketchup into my mouth.
You know what's stopping you?
Take a burger, put it on the bun, and you can squirt a ridiculous amount of mayonnaise.
You guys wanna squirt our mayonnaise onto the same bun together?
Yeah, hold on, let me refill the mayonnaise.
Oh, do we have any mayonnaise left?
Oh yeah, because you ordered like 17 vats of it.
And now it's being utilized.
Yeah, see, this was the plan.
You have to trust the process.
Do we have any more mayonnaise?
No?
Okay, only a lot.
Let's just squirt at a time then.
How do I put the...is this empty?
No, it's not empty.
How do I put...
One more ice cream.
Yeah, put it in the wrapper.
You can do this all by yourself.
You don't need limes.
You don't even know how to put mayonnaise on a fucking bun!
I do!
Look, see?
Look at that.
I did it.
Here you go, Doki.
Would you eat this burger I just made for you?
No.
Anybody want this burger I just made?
Would you eat this mayonnaise?
Thank you.
Gonna put this here.
Put food on tray first while I'm alone.
That's kind of sensational.
Imagine putting 15 squirts of mayonnaise in between these buns and then oiling it up.
You should do it.
What's stopping you?
I would love to see that.
I would love to see what happens in the fire.
This is the sound of my internal dialogue.
Did anyone actually try the Krabby Patty at Wendy's?
No, because I live in England.
Oh sorry, I was talking to the Americans here.
It's a pineapple under the sea.
I was talking to the real people here.
You guys, I'm making the kitchen sink.
You're making what?
The kitchen sink?
I mixed all the sodas together.
Oh!
The classic.
Somebody chug it.
You can wait until it gets warm.
That's when it tastes the most flavorful.
Put it on the grill.
Put it on the grill?
That's true.
Have we ever even had coffee?
We can't.
We don't have coffee beans in the grinder.
I was looking forward to making the frothy milk.
Because it's a funny noise.
Yeah.
It's an even better noise.
There's a barista simulator and it was one of the most stressful simulators I've ever played.
Because it was incredibly realistic.
This felt realistic too.
People in the reviews were saying it reminds me of the time when I was a barista, but not the good way.
You actually have to do the step-by-step on how to make the coffee.
I wanted to cry.
Please respect it.
Intrusive thought.
Did you shove my hand under here?
We should dunk Doki's head into the fryer.
That would be funny.
We don't have any oil though.
Can we order it?
Intrusive.
No, we have to do level 10.
Level 10 unlocks everything.
Look how beautifully clean these fryers are.
I know, right?
There's no contamination.
Wait, there's contamination?
How do you contaminate it?
There's an oil waste jug and you have to empty it out every now and again.
I thought fryers kill off bacteria because it's too hot.
Maybe you can just dump peanut oil in there or something and kill someone.
I don't know.
You have to recycle the grease and filter it.
How do you know so much about it, Snuffy?
I've worked nothing but these shitty 10-Edge jobs in my life.
Doki, have you never worked fast food?
I've never done fast food before.
You're so lucky.
How realistic was this game?
It was pretty realistic, I think.
No.
Wait, Snuffy, is that why you love first-line tech support?
I just... I don't know.
This just gets me going.
I love systematic things.
I love a good burger.
I love Swappies!
See, this is why I felt like Snuffy would've been the best manager.
Don't you fucking start again.
I swear to God.
Have you worked at fast food?
I've worked first-line support and it was fucking miserable.
But no, not fast food.
Exactly.
She has the real-life experiences.
She has...
She spent years in the grind.
She deserves it.
No, you're right.
Limes is the crusty and I'm the Spongebob.
You mean Krabs?
Who's the crusty and who's the Krabs?
Yeah, who's the crusty and who's the Krabs?
Snuffy is the most optimal Spongebob.
I just wanna grill a patty.
She is the most optimal.
No, you're right.
Limes is.
I mean, do you want to try one more?
Because it kinda felt like we were collectively having a mental breakdown.
You know what?
I think Snuffy should solo this.
Go, Snuffy, go.
Snuffy, go.
Alright, everybody in favor of Snuffy...
I can't do this without my sloppy crew.
Say aye.
Aye.
I think Snuffy...
in the spirit of sloppy...
would solo this.
She can solo him.
I don't think so.
I'm only a cog in the wheel...
that turns the sloppy machine.
You gotta dream big, Snuffy.
Holy shit, have you seen our bathrooms here?
They're so big.
That's why I was like...
I think we'll have to...
clean them at some point.
Wait, where's the bathroom?
To the right of the restaurant.
Oh my god, put all the patties in the urinals.
Wait, where are you guys?
Over here.
Over down here, yeah.
We're a real restaurant.
Why is the bathroom so nice?
Little tiny...
Can anybody find...
We should play hide and seek.
Can anybody find me?
I'm serious, though.
Can you find me?
Where the fuck...
Oh, wow.
Great hiding spot.
I like how we opened...
We opened a brand new burger joint...
and it's one of the fanciest, cleanest...
burger joints in the entire world.
The biggest bathrooms ever.
We're called Sloppies.
It's called Sloppies.
I think Sloppies is a good name.
It says famous sauce...
on the side here.
And I'm kind of wondering...
Famous Sloppies sauce?
Famous Sloppies sauce.
The sloppiest of them all.
Big Mac and some Sloppies sauce.
Nice.
I think this is doable.
This is doable...
but I think the same people...
who are making burgers need to be...
There needs to be two up front...
and two in the back, so to speak.
Yeah, but that's what we had.
We can't...
We had a system that keeps track of...
which order we're forming to...
just in case we don't make the same burger.
Once you have two people making the burgers...
it's just like, who's doing what now?
It can't be the Big Mac.
That's copyrighted.
But we can be like the Big Plap.
Like Big Slap.
I want to get the Big Plap at Sloppies.
Perfect.
You guys are genius at marketing.
Sloppy sauce.
Can we get a Big Plap meal...
with extra sloppy sauce on the side?
Is that our signature burger?
That's our signature burger, yeah.
Limited time.
It says the big one up there, but we know the rest.
That's it, the Big Plap.
Does that mean we have the quarter plappy?
The secret sloppy sauce.
The quarter plopper?
No!
Not the quarter plopper!
The plappy meals.
You came up with that!
Welcome to Sloppies, everybody.
Welcome to Sloppies.
Glad to have you here.
Can I take your order?
Uh...
Yes, I'll have a plappy meal with...
What kind of toy do you have today?
I feel at home behind this counter.
I don't want to leave.
Really?
Yeah.
What are your favorite memories from Sloppies?
Oh my god, I've never looked at you guys' faces before.
This makes it worse.
Everyone looks so bad.
We look like we've been through it.
Wait, you're smiling.
Why won't you look happy?
Well, she's usually the manager.
She doesn't have to do the hard work like us.
Mint looks like she spent the last 30 years outside and didn't apply sunscreen even once.
I did.
Mint looks like a cowboy from like 1873.
What do I look like?
You look exactly like Limon.
You look depressed.
Wait, so I look different from Limon and you?
Because you guys look the same, so I look different from...
It's the same face model.
They've just adjusted the skin tone.
I'm going to make the workplace environment really uncomfortable.
Look in the bathroom mirror?
Are we all the men?
Am I a guy wearing a green t-shirt?
No, you're a lady.
It's two ladies, two boys.
What?
Two ladies?
What do you mean?
Yeah, you're a lady.
I'm a lady?
Why did you say I was a cowboy then?
You can be a pretty cowboy.
I'm a pretty cowboy.
Am I a pretty cowboy?
The prettiest.
The prettiest out in the west.
Enjoy avocado, pickles, pepper, always nice fries, premium coffee, family and friends.
What is this fucking word salad shit up here?
Avocado, pickles, pepper, sounds like a pretty cool song.
I thought you were about to rap.
Cheese, chicken, always fresh, farm, own quality, tomato, onion, potato, 100% beef, original taste, spicy salad.
This is the poke rap.
This is like the poke rap.
Cheese, chicken, tomato, onion, delicious, always fresh, quality, farm owed.
You're halfway there.
Do you think everybody walking by just sees us jumping off the chandeliers?
At least 150 or more to see.
To be a sloppy master is my destiny.
I don't know if I want to be a sloppy master.
A sloppy master.
To be a sloppy master is my destiny.
I don't know about that.
You clap me and I clap you.
I think this game broke us a little bit.
This place has been around since 1932.
You guys, we are a stain on this company's history.
Not everybody has what it takes to open a sloppy franchise.
It takes a lot to be a sloppy franchise owner.
What if we stay open long enough there's like a Herobrine situation?
And someone rolls up to the drive-thru.
The clock hasn't changed since 9pm.
It's like we're in a hyperbolic time chamber.
We're trapped.
We're trapped in this, nothing has moved on.
It's our eternal purgatory.
Where we keep making sloppy burgers every day.
Every day.
Every night.
To Snuffy, that's like her heaven right there.
That's like her heaven.
While we're trapped in the purgatory with her.
It's literally the episode where it's like, give it up for day 42.
Dave, yeah, day 42.
This is so if the cats jump on the counter, they get scared.
Wait, where are you guys?
Oh, you're there.
Lime's out here.
Wait, where did Mint go?
Mint's just in there.
Guys, I had a great time with my sloppy employees.
Yeah.
Team Sloppy.
Team where we all had our own individual mental breakdowns.
And then a couple people tried to stage a mutiny.
And then, you know, one at a time got locked in the freezer.
Team Sloppy.
Is that our team name?
Sloppy Squad?
Oh, Sloppy Squad.
The Sloppy Squad?
Alright, yeah.
We're the Slop Sisters.
Oh my god, why is our name getting worse?
We could have stopped, but we can't.
The Slop Sisters?
What is this, fucking Hamilton?
Slop, Slop, Slop.
Alright.
The Sloppy Squad.
Where do we end?
I wanna drink out of the cups really loud like that.
Slop, Slop.
Slop, Slop, Slop.
Just like a cat.
Like a dog, really.
Be specific.
I'm so happy to be here with my Sloppy Squad.
And to many more Slops in the future.
Thank you.
I like how I can open this back up again.
Like someone's gonna just come trundling along at like...
9pm.
That's what Wendy's is for.
That's what Wendy's are for.
Always open and ready to serve.
No matter what time.
9pm is pretty early, I feel like, to close.
Yeah.
I think it's weird for Sloppies to close at 9pm.
Yeah, somebody has a bedtime.
Who is it?
I wonder when you unlock management if you can change that.
Oh, Jesus.
They do actually have the drive-thru.
It just never happens.
It's like out of prologue thing.
I don't think this...
I don't know if this game will get out of prologue.
Let's...
Wait, do they have to drive all the way around the building to the window?
Yeah, they have to drive all the way here.
All the way around, I guess, yeah.
And then order.
No, I think you can drive here.
No, it's right here.
They can do a sick U-turn right here.
Yeah, right here.
They come in, they do a U-turn, and then they drive through, do a U-turn.
Yeah, it's like an initial D.
Somebody in my chat said...
If we open a second location, we can call it Sloppy Seconds.
What?
Oh my
gosh, eventually we'd get donuts.
This is like our food truck.
Sloppy on Wheels.
You know what?
No, that sounds like...
That's actually a pretty decent food truck name, not gonna lie.
Sloppy on Wheels.
Sounds good.
Get your slop on the go.
We gotta...
We gotta copyright this right now.
Guys, we can't have them...
We can't have them take it.
It'll be the next big thing.
How about the police show up and we're just a bunch of hoodlums like drugged up in the parking lot.
The police are gonna come in and be like...
We got some calls here about some...
Yeah, we're just like...
Banging on the drive-thru window.
We're all just screaming sloppies.
Oh!
Did we make any money?
No.
Only $74 is what we lost.
That's not bad.
We got minus $805 popularity for opening up and just sitting here all day.
That might be a good thing though.
We didn't want that.
Just don't open the restaurant.
Don't open the restaurant.
Don't do it.
Stop it, please.
Without the sloppy sister.
Don't.
Stop.
Please have mercy on us.
I think we gotta sell the franchise before it goes bunk.
Do you sell high?
Oh, true.
Sell high.
I don't think there's any high here.
We failed in every metric.
We still have a positive rating.
Yeah, we're level 8.
Look, see?
They're like...
They're just content with us, you know?
They're not disappointed.
I don't know if that's a content face.
We're like an Arby's.
It's kind of a resignation face.
I have an idea.
You guys, we climb that mountain.
Cause an avalanche.
And then we collect the insurance.
We collect the insurance on the building.
I don't think they even put that to the insurance scam back in the game.
I think we could dig like a crevasse underneath the building of sloppies.
And then it'll cave in and we can blame it on natural causes.
Oh, that's true.
Wait until there's a rainstorm.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We got a sinkhole under sloppies.
It's like that lady on TikTok that made an underground mine before she got shut down.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can hire her.
She still wants to make that mine.
Make the sloppy sinkhole.
Sloppy sinkhole.
Sloppy hole.
Trademark that, trademark that.
Manager, you should trademark that.
So they don't steal our idea.
Guys, I'm gonna miss it here.
I'm gonna really miss it.
I'm gonna miss all the memories we have here before we burn this place down.
Sloppy sinkhole was just my name in college.
I can't trademark that.
I need to go get something to eat.
Get T.T.'s.
T.T.
T .T.
I'll get the girls fired up.
Let's go.
Quit.
I just get it past that.
No.
No more sloppy.
Oh no.
Sloppy's is dead forever.
I hope there's an update where you can dress up as the mascot.
I know.
I wanna be the sign twirler.
Do the sign twirls and everything.
It's like a rhythm game.
You have to like...
You're just playing a different game from us.
You're just...
We need extra hands back here.
There's too many ingredients.
I'm styling.
I've got my earphones in too.
We just hear the clickly clack of the keyboard and being like...
Please, we need somebody to bring these orders in.
And you're just like...
Oh, suing it up on your screen.
Well, that was fun, guys.
I had a great time with all of you guys.
Thanks for suggesting this.
I had a very good time.
Yeah, no problem.
It was...
Bye bye.
By the way, guys.
It's not even out yet.
What do you mean?
I'm so sad.
I like how different that was compared to...
Shopkeeper Sim is kind of...
There's stuff to do, but it's still mostly chill...
for a lot of levels.
Whereas that game was just like...
If you want something more than one ingredient, go fuck yourself.
It's actually very...
Very...
Accurate to the real thing.
It was like Overcooked.
If Overcooked had no appealing art style...
Honestly, I think this was...
Much more difficult than Overcooked.
Oh my god, someone just...
In my chat was just like...
I played this stream over the speaker in the kitchen...
And we were laughing.
Like a real kitchen was watching us working.
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
But I still...I'm glad that...
I was able to open a fast food restaurant...
With all of you guys.
The Sloppy Squad.
One day Sloppies will write again.
Yeah, one day.
One day we'll bring back...
Sloppies will come back, guys.
Let's see what...
What if we had like a...
What if we had like a cafe collab...
And it was just Sloppies?
Oh my god.
Whatever we do with food...
It's always Sloppies.
Sloppies, yeah.
Our cafe collab is just...
Literally Sloppies...
And themed around...
We're just doing Papa's Pizzeria, Freezeria.
So Sloppies under different...
Circumstances, this is Sloppies Dessert.
Sloppies Dessert?
Okay, maybe not.
I mean, cha-ching.
Sloppies Sweets.
Everybody would want a part of Sloppies.
Who's everybody?
Sloppies Craftery?
I'm that guy.
No.
But thank you everyone for...
Doing another collab again.
It was really fun.
Thank you for inviting.
My mind is always a bug with you guys.
Thank you.
I feel like next time...
We should just hang out and talk on stream.
Because I feel like...
I feel like...
Think of something that we can play...
In the background really idly.
If anything.
Something that you can play.
Maybe involving fishing.
With your friends on the web.
I don't know.
Oh yeah, the we...
The we fishing or whatever.
Web fishing.
I was playing it yesterday.
It's really chill.
You should try it.
It's actually really chill.
Is it fun?
Okay, I'll try.
It's basically like Animal Crossing fishing.
But they remove everything else.
And it's just fishing.
It's just the fishing part of Animal Crossing.
So you can shitpost at your friends at the same time.
Yeah.
Do you like any VR collabs?
Oh yeah.
We should do VR together.
Snuffy knows all about VR stuff.
You can give us a tour.
Show us your favorite worlds.
Yeah.
There's a ton of Halloween stuff to you that's scary.
Wait, scary?
I need to poke you about something in regards to that Snuffy.
I will message you after.
Oh, secret.
I want to be involved.
That's fine.
I'll poke everybody.
It is very easy to get me to just be like...
You want to know too?
Okay, I'll tell you.
Yeah.
We want to know.
Get excited.
Cool.
Okay, well thank you guys.
Teaching everybody.
See you guys later.
Bye-bye.
Guys...
My brain is literally sloppy right now.
My brain is...
I can't even think.
My brain is mush.
What a crazy...
Oh my god.
I'm exhausted from laughing.
I'm glad you guys thought it was funny.
I hope you guys...
Had fun.
Me?
I'm gonna go eat...
Dinner.
Oh my gosh, it's so early.
Wow.
Wasn't that long of a collab.
But that's okay, because it was craziness.
I was crying from laughing.
We didn't make it to level 10.
But thank god we didn't make it to level 10.
Oh my gosh, I've worked fast food before.
I worked at a Wendy's.
I worked...
I worked like third shift or whatever.
So it was like...
It was like...
6pm to 3am or something.
I got PTSD from when I worked at Tim Horton's.
5 out of 5 would eat at Sloppy's again.
Would you actually?
Yeah, I did.
It was so awful.
I would...
Thank you!
Sorry if you guys were sending stuff.
And I couldn't see, but thank you.
That collab was incredible and re-traumatizing.
It was.
Night shift closers represent.
Yeah, and then...
My...
So I wasn't properly trained on the register.
So...
I had a lot of anxiety that if...
I made a mistake when someone was ordering.
Or if they wanted to change an order.
I like, couldn't.
So I never was taught how.
And so...
So I wouldn't change their order.
And then, they would get up to the thing.
And they would be like...
Oh, this is my order.
Or they'd be like, is this your order?
And they'd be like, oh, I changed this.
And then they would be like...
Oh, okay.
We'll fix it.
And then, at the end of the night.
Everybody would leave.
And have me finish closing up.
I was...
I was not just register though.
I was back register and dishes.
So I was also washing the dishes.
And it would be like...
At night, I would have to wash the huge thing.
That like, all the fries were in.
And it was big and heavy.
And I couldn't properly wash it.
It was so bad.
This is reinforced why I no longer work fast food service.
Did they find your stash of burgers at the counter?
Oh,
yeah.
That thing is a pain to wash.
It's so awful.
Cleaning the grease vat at closing was so gross.
I know, it made me feel so awful.
And then, after I worked there.
I worked at a different...
It wasn't quite fast food.
But I worked at a different...
I worked at another food place.
Called in today because I had a horrid day yesterday.
And I do work at food service.
This is way too accurate, but y'all tune it up.
Sorry, Teresa.
Sorry.
When they were like, number 5, this is for table 5.
I was like, losing my mind.
I was like, this is too real.
This is too real.
Like a chain restaurant.
It was, kind of.
It was like...
It was like pseudo fast food.
You know what I mean?
But it is like a nationwide chain.
I don't know.
I don't feel it.
I don't know why.
I don't want to say it.
I don't want to give up my whole work experience.
Fast casual.
Wait, is that a real word?
Not hooters.
I've never even been to a hooters before.
I once went to one.
And they were really busy.
And I remember seeing a girl in the back.
With the fattest hooters.
And I was like, please, can we stay?
But they were just so busy.
And we wouldn't get a table for a really long time.
So...
I was so sad.
Woah, mama.
Anyways, I'm so sorry.
You guys, usually in these kinds of collabs...
I'm able to look at chat...
Even just a little bit.
But for this...
I was totally focused on the game.
So I'm so sorry.
But hopefully you guys still have fun.
And everything.
I had a lot of fun.
Sloppies.
So sloppies.
It was a fast food trauma.
It truly was.
Hooters is America's version of Japan's maid cafe.
That's why I have to go.
Do they do checkies at Hooters?
If I brought my checkie camera, would they do a checkie with me?
Sloppies is second to none.
Exactly, exactly.
Okidoki.
Well guys, I think I'm gonna head out now.
You guys have a sloppy day?
Sloppy night?
I'm really in the mood for a sloppy joe now.
I've been thinking about it the whole time.
Thanks for the sloppy good collab.
Thank you guys.
Hell yeah.
Sloppy joe.
Go grab a berg.
I don't think I'll get a berg, but...
I can like smell...
I could smell this collab.
Thanks for the streaming though.
Thanks for watching!
This brought back a whole lot of PTSD of my minimum wage days.
So I'm grateful for my office job now.
Yes.
And if you work in food service now...
It can always get better.
Or...
You're out of sloppies.
Try to print this.
Thank you.
Thanks guys!
Otsu minto!
Otsu bastion!
And see you guys not tomorrow.
I'm not streaming tomorrow, but I'll see you guys...
When I see you!
Otsu minto!
Bye bye!
Thank you guys!
See you!
Thanks for the 20k thread!
Thank you so much!
Bye bye!